Oh wait a minute,
we didn't even like this.
Hmm.
Like
this is the sound of freedom.
That's freedom.
As it exhales your body as Mother Nature,
his mother Gaia enters into your system.
There were a series of cannabinoid receptors.
Hmm.
I'm good dude.
Starting a new non political party.
Sammy.
I don't think anybody should be in a political party anymore.
I agree.
But uh,
and uh,
out of respect for the great hunter s Thompson,
I'm going to call it the freak party.
Man.
Dick.
I feel like a freak.
I don't feel like I,
I'm represented.
I,
uh,
will never vote for any of the two major parties ever get even libertarians.
They fucking freaked me out.
A bunch of Weirdos.
Much a preppers.
Oh,
all of you.
Not all.
If you don't get crazy,
you don't get picky.
Say the hate mail.
I will only vote for someone if I don't know who they are.
That doesn't help.
Yeah.
Because well,
yeah,
it does know who they are and there's some fucking freak NSA under ground secret
infiltrator agent type character Sam.
Okay.
That could go if my vote ruin society,
I understand that,
but I just vote for anybody who can't afford to campaign.
That's pretty much,
well,
that might be better than what we're doing already,
but it might not be too.
That's possible as well.
You know,
we need to do Sam,
we need to educate the people.
Is that possible?
This is a way to do it and one of the ways is audible.com oh really?
I'd love to hear about it.
Well,
automotive.com is the number one source of audio entertainment and education on
the Internet more than a hundred thousand different titles.
You can't possibly read 100,000 fucking things,
but you might be able to put a good dent into it if you got in your car or if
you were on a train or on a plane and listen to audio books more at the gym or
jogging.
If you're one of those nature at the park type characters that's not worried
about muggers and you're running around with a fucking thing on,
not worried about getting clipped over the head by someone who's sneaking up
behind you.
You don't see them coming or maybe you just fucking that confident and your,
your foot speed.
You dislike this motherfucking mugger try to catch me bitch.
Yeah.
Try to catch me.
My cardio is off the charts.
Go to audible.com.
Forward Slash Joe,
you will get one free audio book and 30 free days of audible service.
And audible has a gigantic selection of fiction,
nonfiction.
They have the opiod Anthony Radio shows.
They have stand up comedy.
You can get my shit on audible.
You can get so many different books.
There's an a amazing,
uh,
pile of awesome titles,
in every single category.
Um,
I recommend Steven Pressfield's the war of art.
This is a book that I've been recommended to everybody.
I,
it's such a good book as far as like motivation to get your shit together that
I bought stacks of them and I used to hand them out to people all the time.
Um,
and then I got tired of it and I was like,
pick gay shit together,
bitch.
What am I doing?
I'm trying to fucking motivate other people.
I listen to audible.
I actually use it.
Yeah,
it's very good.
I love it.
I,
uh,
the a book that I love to listen to,
I was a behold a pale horse.
That was a good thing.
I had read it,
but it was fun to hear back down is some re ridiculous shit.
It's fun to listen to man.
It's actually,
when you look back at like what he's saying then and what's going on now,
you're like,
Whoa,
well his book is like,
I can't recommend it.
I'm of it.
You can't recommend it enough.
I love it,
dude.
You got to smoke a fat joint before you read that and then just shut it off,
walk away.
Um,
there's some really interesting stuff in there and some complete nonsense.
It's really like if you wanted to pick a book where you were worried or curious
whether or not like there was some disinflation of foot,
whether they were trying to connect really,
you know,
actual factual ideas with fucking bs UFO basis at Walmart.
You know,
this is the book.
So you're saying there's a little truth,
but there's also a lot of misinformation.
I'm sure there's some truth in that.
Well,
even crazy people can count.
You know,
even if you're completely out of your mind,
you make a bunch of shit up.
You might know how to turn on a laptop.
A broken clock is right twice a day.
That's so true.
Sam Tripoli.
I'm so glad when people say that shit.
Anyway,
go to audible.com forward slash Joe Steve Martin's books good too.
Yes,
it is.
Right.
What is it born standings and what it is.
Steve Martin's awesome and he actually reads his book.
Uh,
and uh,
or you could that guy from a fucking,
what's it called?
The beard guy.
Sy.
The one that Joey Diaz from the duck dynasty.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I was that guy.
He really loves that guy.
He's not a note.
No bullshit.
He loves that guy crushing it.
Fuck yet is it?
She'll kick my,
his ass really stomped it here.
You're up against a family though.
And Dennis Miller vernacular,
like a narc at a biker rally.
Um,
anyway,
audible.com four slash Joe and a get a free audio book.
It's worth it.
You'll love it.
And it's,
it's a great way to entertain yourself.
Um,
basically just like podcasting,
I'm essentially cutting out my own hamstrings telling you about this.
It is,
it is.
We're also brought to you by Lumosity.
Lumosity is one of our newest sponsors and Lumosity is a new service.
It's a website that's designed to improve your mental health.
It's really interesting.
It's like workouts for your mind and they're like fun games and I've been doing
it.
I don't know if I'm any smarter yet,
but um,
it's easy.
It's enjoyable.
Um,
and you can personalize it for you.
Different performance goals as far as your brain,
does it have a little sound effect on it?
Well that's a chalk one against Lumosity.
Okay.
Let me tell you something.
Nobody wants fucking sound effects on their website.
We're tired of that.
This is the worst thing when you go to someone's website,
no song plays.
All right.
That's why I hate about my space.
Like back in the day,
you couldn't look at other girls like website pages.
Cause of song would jump up your girlfriends.
Like what are you listening to you like close,
close,
close.
And it would make you,
it would crush your website,
your browser tabs.
Someone always had some wacky thing running in the background too much.
And you get to,
it's like,
what is this?
Especially the Asian chicks could really go off on their pages,
sparkled tanks.
That's where we learned about the world.
We're in about sparkled tags.
Ah,
you can play online at work.
I wouldn't recommend playing at work cause then you're not working.
And,
uh,
I think if you're gonna do something,
she just fucking do it.
Unless your job really sucks the fat deck and you're looking to get out and you
listen to this podcast during work right now.
And I would say keep doing what you're doing.
Follow your instincts,
go towards the light.
Do you have a black belt in this yet?
Yes,
I've got a black problem on my God,
my friend play online at work,
at home,
even from an iPhone or an iPad with the Lumosity APP,
it takes,
it doesn't say anything about android.
I guess they're haters.
Uh,
with Lumosity you can track your progress online while seeing the actual
improvements in your everyday life.
Um,
and when you go to Lumosity,
just tell them that I sent you just,
I think it's a reference box.
Who,
well,
how'd you find a little bit Lumos Joe Rogan Bitch.
And you can say that to fish.
I probably won't even get credit for it,
but it'd be funnier.
So go ahead.
Say Joe Rogan Bitch.
I'm like,
well,
Joe Rogan,
it seems that no one from your show went to Lumosity,
but everybody from Joe Rogan bitch went there.
Um,
Joe Rogan calm a bitch.
Would that get passed?
It's dot,
dot,
dot.
Bitch.
Um,
what I like about it I think is interesting is you can,
you can personalize your goals,
uh,
which is,
it's kind of kind of odd when you first started doing it because you're like,
wait a minute.
You can,
you can,
why not?
Why wouldn't it be better to click everything?
I guess maybe it'd be too difficult,
but as you're doing it,
like it gives you,
like memory gives you a bunch of options.
Recalling the location of objects,
remembering the names after first introduction,
which I suck a fat one at.
Do you,
are you good at remembering people's names or an FTE meet him?
No,
I'm horrible at it.
People always think my memory's really good because I remember fights.
Like if you ask me about MMA,
I can pull MMA.
I'll pull a heath,
Keith Hackney fight.
Keith Hackney versus Joe Sohn know from 93 94 I can,
I'll tell you what happened in that fight.
I'll talk to you about ball punches,
detail.
I remember some things.
Yeah,
I remember some things,
but my memory's not the best if I don't care,
you rock those Russian and European names at the weigh ins.
I'm always impressed by that.
They have to go over those with me several times.
I fucked up homie.
Lawn check though.
Oh,
me lawn check was a guy that fought this last weekend in Toronto.
It was so hard.
Only launch [inaudible] it's,
it's weird the way it's written.
Tough guy though.
Um,
you can keep track of several ideas at the same time.
Allegedly.
I'm a little skeptical.
Sam,
the [inaudible].
Right?
How are you going to fix my broken brain son?
Fears broken?
My must be the Ahhbra hands are broken.
The heap,
they're flawed.
You know,
it helps it now for brain.
Take some right now while I'm on the podcast.
Oh,
Elsa brains for it.
Yeah.
Alpha brains.
I wonder if it improves the score was the word on nasty.
Hmm.
Uh,
the words on one an Alpha brain.
It's delicious.
It's nutritious.
Good for the whole family dome.
Uh,
attention,
maintain focus on important tasks.
MMM.
For those who've been asking about Alpha brand,
we'll talk about that next.
But the studies on Alpha brain will finally be published,
uh,
allegedly in February.
It takes a long time to get into a scientific journal about stuff.
So people have been asking about the results of the double blind,
the seat placebo tests.
Um,
we did what's called a pilot test and then we're going to do a big fat test
after this.
Uh,
but it's because of the pilot test is very encouraging.
Um,
I guess that would help you if you took a little more,
do a Mazda.
I think the idea behind something like Lumosity is that your brain,
much like everything else grows in strength with repetition and folks.
Uh,
it seems to work as far as like my brain when it comes to standup comedy,
the more I'm doing stand up,
the more I'm like,
the more I'm in that standup comedy vibe.
It seems like a mental shape.
Like you get in comedy shape,
right?
You feel like that?
Yeah.
He ever take like two weeks off from standup.
I took a few months off and you go back to it,
you're like,
whoa.
It's like you think you're just going to step right into it and start running
and you're like,
if your timing's a little off,
it's,
what was that line there?
It's not,
I figured out though how to stop that from happening.
Record yourself.
Really?
Yeah,
it's big.
It's huge.
What do you do with that?
You just play back or do you upload it to something?
Well,
play it back and take notes.
Listen and take note to that dude.
It's hard to do because it's work.
It's work.
You don't wanna listen to yourself gross.
Like,
I do hate lik in myself.
I've got to edit this CD and I just can't listen to myself.
Jim Norton told me that when he was,
when he was a editing,
his is a special,
which was very funny by the way.
You want wanted to hang himself.
He put a fucking belt up,
uh,
on the coat hanger in the closet.
He goes,
I wasn't going to do it,
but I just put it up there.
I just wanted to let myself know I fucking suck.
Yeah,
you were thinking about hang on yourself once he goes,
I wasn't,
wasn't that wasn't actually going to go through with it,
but it was like,
whoa.
You keep it on the table.
That's how bad comedians hate listen to themselves and if you talk to a
committee with loves,
listened himself,
he's hurt too.
There are people like to play back their stuff over and over again.
You're like,
oh,
what's wrong about the it for you?
Hey,
listen to this.
Listen to this bit.
I did listen this bit.
I did.
I'll just listen to this one bit.
No,
no.
Down,
down,
down now.
Now know,
um,
another thing that Lumosity helps is flexibility.
The idea of mental flexibility,
communicating clearly.
You know,
sometimes when you're communicating it's difficult to find the right way to
describe something.
The idea is that the more often you do that,
the easier it will be.
And I think that it's absolutely
true because when I think about the things that I do,
like a lot of the things that I do like,
like MMA commentary would be very difficult to do if you hadn't done it before.
And the more you do it,
the more you get sort of sharp at it.
Um,
well Lumosity treats it like that.
There's exercises you can do that will allow you to be flexible in your ideas
and that sort of a way.
Thinking outside the box,
avoiding errors,
multitasking.
How's your multitasking skills,
Sim,
sharepoint Kim,
and incredibly hard and incredibly bad about as bad as can be.
Right?
Right.
Comedians are the worst fucking multitaskers in the history of the world.
Pulse of Shitheads,
multitasking butts,
a bad,
it's add version of multitasking where like,
I tried to do 90 things,
but yet nothing gets done.
You're like,
ah man,
I want to do this over here.
And then at the end of the day I'm like,
I've got nothing accomplished.
Every time I talked to Brian Kelly wants to fucking start yachting and wants a,
I want to go sail boating.
I think I'm thinking about doing a sambo,
maybe Samba and Samba old under dance and choke people like,
dude,
stop,
stop.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He wants to do everything got done.
Telling me like I was talking about being gluten free.
I've been gluten free for like three months ago.
See,
I don't,
I don't need any of that stuff.
You know,
brands and brand.
I go,
you just had a sandwich right in front of me and you had bread with dinner last
night.
I saw you buttered bread.
He goes,
this I believe very little live it.
I barely eat any of it.
I go,
you had bread every time.
You hadn't been here.
You've been here for three days.
You've had bread every single day.
Like what are you talking about?
You guys are both pretty shredded for your eyes,
man.
I'm pretty impressed.
He just saw my socks.
Me.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Side got uncomfortable that he's gluten free.
I'm like,
you're not gluten free.
You're fucking line.
Do you eat bread every Goddamn Day?
He,
it's a story fits his reality.
He wants,
he's hilarious.
But it's that most entertaining.
One of the most entertaining dudes I've ever met.
We did a USO together and we'd flew cross country and everybody was jet lagged
and we have,
when you do a Uso,
you've got to meet everybody at the base.
It's a big day for them.
The comedians are going to come around and you meet everybody.
You go on this like mini tour of the base.
You meet everybody and they tell you what they do.
Man,
everybody was jet lag.
But ma'am,
Brian put on a show dude,
he was just on for,
I mean just what you see on stage he was doing in their offices.
So when he came up onto the stage and I introduced them,
first guy up,
walked up to a standing out,
he'd already made you loved everybody mentally that they'd love them right out
the gate.
You already told the story on this podcast before,
but it's a great story.
Well thank you.
It's a great story.
It's in a while.
That is Brian Cowen.
That is,
I remember it because I remember you saying about everybody.
Not that I haven't told a million fucking stories.
Sometimes I forget what.
So I've told Dude,
we're almost 400 podcasts.
The each one of them is like at least two hours.
Most of them three hours long.
So how the fuck could you pause when you got,
when it comes to stand up,
do you ever find yourself somewhat repeating a premise even though it's kind of
a different take,
but the same kind of premise?
I mean like,
cause like I'm learning that
your perspective on stuff is almost the same and there's only so much.
Maybe the talk about,
I don't know.
I feel like even with myself I've seen where you're like,
okay,
that's a lot like an old joke I used to tell.
Yeah,
it's very possible.
Anyway,
Lumosity got com.
Yeah,
check it out.
Tell him,
tell him Joe Rogan San.
Yeah.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com that's o.N ,
N.
I t.
If you haven't seen a new primal bells in,
there's three of them.
Now there's a gorilla,
a chimpanzee,
and a new orangutan.
And uh,
every time someone buys an orangutan,
five bucks goes to help save orangutans.
All these animals,
chimps,
gorillas,
they're all endangered.
It's,
uh,
you know,
were assholes and we liked to kill monkeys.
I mean,
that's just,
that's a fact.
Horrible.
It's a,
I say we as in human race,
not Sam and I and not Jamie either.
And he's not a monkey killer by any stretch of the imagination.
Spanked Monkey.
That's about it.
Monkeys are [inaudible] a bunch of monkeys killed a guy in India.
I don't know,
maybe the Indian guy started it.
He might have been a dick,
but these are monkeys.
Anyway,
there apes,
people get real specific about that.
You see monkey boots really mean.
Yes.
I mean,
a guide can send people,
gorillas,
orangutans,
chimps.
I work out with them and myself.
They're cool.
I like to fantasize when I work out.
And,
uh,
my fantasy is that one of these things is trying to fuck me up.
I get scared.
You're holding onto a look at that chimpanzee face.
That's an evil or the gorilla to look at that motherfucker.
He might've,
that motherfucker was hovering over you about to put a beat down on you.
What do you do,
man?
You curl up in a ball and he probably gets tired of beating the shit out of you
and that's probably not going to help.
He's probably going to take you apart like a fucking pistachio nut,
like the shell of a nut snap and just separate you.
Oh,
you're so strong.
We can't even wrap our heads around how strong this fucking thing.
So,
but uh,
you can be stronger with primal bills.
We sell regular kettle bells too if you're one of those conservative no nonsense
type who does a traditional cal and see.
But if the kettle bells that we serve,
we sell as far as the primal bells,
the only go up to 72 pounds.
But as far as the regular plain ones,
we have them,
um,
up to 90 pounds.
And if you can lift one of those 90 pound things,
you are a motherfucker.
That's impressive.
Shit.
I don't do social status.
You have reached motherfuckers status,
motherfucker status 90 pound kettle bell will also be sure to Piss your mailman
off to no end and make no mistake about it.
When I picked up to 70 pound one to look,
they had in their face,
they wanted to fucking drop it on my Dick.
That'd be uncomfortable.
A bunch of women working there as well and it's really not fair.
I wish they would let me know when they're coming in and I would be there to
load it off the truck.
That involves teamwork.
Hmm.
Oh,
you know there was lot of that too.
Let me know when it reaches the post office.
I'll go get it.
Don't,
don't bring it to me.
Me Lift some 70 pound back.
Anyway,
for savagery,
go to [inaudible] dot com we saw all kinds of shit,
protein supplements,
the brain of course,
shroom tech,
sport,
new mood.
If you ever tried any new mood Samwise no,
I have not.
It's very good for you.
It's five HTP and l tryptofan enhancement.
I need that for your serotonin.
Um,
El Tryptofan actually converts to five HTP and five HTP actually does enhance
your mood.
You should be very careful about it though,
if you're on medication,
especially if you're on SSR.
I's of those are a lot of the antidepressants they tell people,
do not take five HTP while you're taking an Ssri because too much serotonin is
not a good thing.
That's a lot of paperwork.
Got It.
Be Falls on.
Oh,
all right.
So go,
uh,
go to [inaudible] dot com check out everything.
And if you use a code name Brogan,
you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
Beautiful,
talented and delicious young Sandwich Tripoli's here.
Right?
You should get like one thing that they say in everything
thing.
What's that like Rogan,
bitch.
They
should have an owl.
Your all your companies about me,
man.
Don't worry about me choosing music.
Sam's hair
experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
I've got an official Sam Tripoli,
the naughty show tee shirt on right now.
This gentleman,
you could buy these,
uh,
at Walmart,
Burger King,
food chains all over the place.
All over the country.
They're going to sell them a NASA.
They're going to sell him on the space shuttle.
Those bitches get bored of [inaudible] dot net.
Check it out by shirt.
If you've never seen Sam show,
it's um,
he puts together stand up comedy with a bunch of crazy videos and I was there
once and I saw a girl beat a man with a belt.
Yeah,
it was pretty,
that was classic non show.
If there's a lot of porn stars answering trivia questions,
it's a,
it's basically chaos.
It is.
It's a big crazy,
chaotic,
silly,
fast.
It's a comedy circus man.
Much like Sam's mind.
Yes it is.
It's all over the place.
That's your mind.
And that's the kind of show you create all the outlaws.
You know,
people focus on the adult film stars and they're really just a small part of a
huge thing and it's just bringing out all this,
you know,
you call them savages all the late night rumblers that people who like can't get
on the tonight show,
like all these crazy burlesque people and comics come and doing real con like
comedy they want to do and just crazy pole dancers who like,
I mean like it's madness saying it is madness.
I've done it several times and a,
it's always a great crowd.
I mean,
even though it's madness,
they're really fun people.
They,
they're there to have a good time.
When's your next one?
Ah,
we're,
we're thinking about doing an October 25th at this place called lyrics on
labrea.
I wouldn't say it's really not out.
Yeah,
I like to move into different places,
man.
You know,
the comedy store is great,
but it's time to move it somewhere else and try a little different.
You know,
I was trying to do Beecher's madhouse,
but that guy,
it's a little crazy over there.
Great Guy.
It just didn't work out.
So I got this new room and it's lyrics and it's a nice room.
Sits about one 50
and Warren,
we're going to crush.
Yep.
Very nice.
And so this is uh,
October 20 what?
25th what day is that?
That's a a Friday night.
Sweet Baby Jesus.
But to 24th,
October 24th I also do a new awesome show that you got to check out.
It's called the comedy rap battles.
It's like eight mile meets standup comedy and it's awesome.
It is awesome.
It comedy rap battles.
Yeah,
Dude.
Comedians do like a five minute set and then they go like,
they rap,
they have a rap battle and dude,
people light each other up is the most entertaining show you'll ever see.
Man.
I,
it's the best.
I'm so proud of it.
And I worked with a bunch of,
uh,
Chris Byrne and a whole bunch of other guys and we put together and man,
it just crushes.
Now have any comedians lashed out physically at any other comedians during a rap
battle?
No.
No,
no.
I think everybody gets it.
It's like they feel bad if they don't light somebody up.
But people get lit up,
lit up.
It does happen in the wrap ones though.
It's occasionally do punch each other.
Oh yeah.
I mean some of those guys get pretty nasty and personal.
They go after the moms.
I think these comedians more light,
but they're vicious.
A,
it's a fun show,
man.
I,
I'm really impressed by,
we're getting some big name djs coming down to this one,
at the Improv on the 24th and it's going to be a great show,
man.
It's going to be a great,
sounds awesome.
That sounds fun.
Do you know who's on the,
on the card,
like the full card?
Ah,
I put it together still for the rap battle.
Some of these people,
like they're really great comics are like,
you can't advertise me.
I'm like,
well,
what are we doing?
But the minute they tell you you can't.
Yeah.
There's a couple people who like,
yeah,
I want to do it,
but it can't advertise you.
Why is that?
I don't know,
man.
That's silly.
That is silly.
I don't get that.
I don't get it either.
That was a big thing at the store.
People didn't want their names up on the marquee like why some comics who just
like that ma'am.
But we're making it a whole big up block party.
We're taking a whole like a parking lot of the Improv.
We're going to have outside Djs,
dancers everywhere.
It's going to be a whole crazy ass thing.
The only thing that I could make that make sense to me about not wanting your
names,
if you're trying to a totally new shit and you want a completely neutral
audience,
like you don't want people that are there for you.
They might give you a little bit of extra juice that you don't deserve the bit
you don't want to do.
Say you don't want to work at any new material in front of your crowd cause you
know that they're going to laugh at it.
You want to try different.
That is a possibility.
There is that and is also that you might not want to do it for your crop because
it's not ready yet.
So you feel like I'm okay to do it in front of these random folks,
but people are paying to see me.
The bits aren't ready yet.
Is that a hard thing?
It could be that.
Some bits,
some bits are just weird man.
Some bids they come together like I like,
I've got a few bits that literally like the day I wrote them,
they were done at least in a basic structural form.
But there's other ones like they're always moving them around.
I put the end in the beginning,
the beginning and the end and know it's funny.
You're like there's something there.
I just got to mine it to get it.
[inaudible] got this one right now,
man,
I got this one right now.
It either kills or it sucks a fat dick man.
No,
I know like when it's in the middle,
whether or not it's going to be one or the other and I know that I have to stick
with it even if it's sucking a fat dick and try to find the way out.
Now,
do you recall,
you say you record it.
Is it ever like a certain word makes it go different?
I find like sometimes when I say it one way it blows up and then if I forget to
do that way,
just fucking flat lines of the room.
Sometimes it's hard to see when you're the guy doing it too.
Like you need to like step back and listened to it.
And when you listen to it and you're all quiet,
you're not saying a word,
you listening to yourself.
Sometimes you go,
oh that comes out wrong.
You know,
I met,
it sounds more like this.
Or maybe people would could possibly think that instead of this or you know,
it's just good to listen to it.
It's not fun.
It's not enjoyable,
you know?
But like if I'm,
especially if I'm on a plane or something like that and I got to go somewhere,
I just listened to my sets.
Like we were talking earlier about like,
uh,
getting really rusty.
The thing that saves you from getting really rusty is listing to sets,
listening,
going over the beds,
making notes.
Then once you start doing it,
it'll kind of come out naturally.
I think you're totally right.
I should do it more.
I don't know why I don't.
I just,
I just liked to do it organically and I think it's a horrible cause.
You're a lazy bitch dude.
You'd say I'm a lazy bitch.
It's that.
The first thing you said that I just,
I work,
I got million irons going.
Hmm,
I'm just going a million irons going from the moment I wake up to the mom,
I go to bed.
I'm just working these irons.
But you're also working some irons that are unnecessary in comparison to that
iron,
maybe iron of sitting and listening to material.
But that requires,
that's actually like work.
It's like writing,
like sitting in front of a computer and writing.
There's a lot of friends that I know that a really good comedians that don't
ever do that and they just can't add out themselves enough to sit in front of a
laptop and just right or sit in front of a notebook and just,
right.
They can't do it.
So they come up with all these excuses.
I,
I write in my head like I've found it.
If I put it down,
it takes away.
It just something in the delivery isn't the same one.
I structure it out.
But what I do is,
you know,
cause I've this be driving around taking care.
I just worked a bit in my head over and over again and over and I'll try to go
up on stage.
What about three or four new jokes with it,
kind of beat it out and then I let kind of the crowd kind of feel it and I just
kind of go with it.
But I don't necessarily sit down and type.
I wish I could,
I just,
I'll write down in my joke premise this prince prince dependent premise and I'll
work them out in my head and then I'll go on stage and I'd be like,
okay that works.
That doesn't work.
And I make mental notes in my head.
Well I definitely have done that before and I think that if that works for you,
it's all really about how much focus you're putting into it.
If your focus is you just sitting in there,
going over it and redoing it over and over again in your head and then just
writing down the premise.
I think that's basically just like writing.
It's just you're not actually putting it down on a piece of paper.
The one thing about writing though is they say that especially physically
writing like pen and paper and not,
not just typing.
When you physically write something,
it helps memory retention and aids.
Like quite a bit like the,
I always um,
if you look at my notebook,
like from my comedy notebook,
it looks like I'm a crazy person.
I'm sure it's the same thing written over and over and over and over and over
again.
It's like all work.
No play makes jack a dull boy because that's what I do when I'm,
when I'm writing my,
my bits out before a show,
I'm just trying to get the key components like seared into my brain and then
from there I,
right,
right.
I like that.
I know that about you.
I wish I could do that.
It's just,
I've tried to be like the guy who sits down like I'm going to write this out and
then go on stage.
He just does it.
Just something gets lost in translation.
But I just,
I mean I'm talking to myself in my head constantly.
My I used to do when I worked at the standard hotel,
they used to think I was crazy guy and the Hispanic,
uh,
maid service wouldn't sit next to me during lunch because they would see me
talking to myself all day just working on the bit,
acting it out just to get through the day of this job that I was very thankful
for,
but it was killing my soul.
But that's how I would get through today day.
Just working on these bits,
playing them out my head.
And then by the time I got on stage,
I would have
somewhat crafted bit Ra onstage.
Yeah,
I used to do that when I drove limos.
I used to drive around and pretend like I was doing the bid I was,
I was driving.
I find that like when you're doing certain tasks,
like especially driving with no radio on,
driving with no radio on is a good thing to do and not enough people do it,
but just driving around and just thinking like sometimes you can figure some
shit out and you have ideas that come to you because you're not being inundated
by constant ideas of other people,
whether it's advertisements or songs you don't really want to hear.
And changing channels,
deciding what the,
listen to silence.
Just drive sometimes and the ideas can come to you.
I completely agree with that.
I've been now trying to talk more stories on stage and it's a little,
it's a transition.
It's not as easy as I thought it was going to be,
but you got to just work through it.
And now that you know,
I've been on stage,
I'm trying to be a little more honest with what's gone in my life because I've
had a crazy life,
what,
you know,
what my drug problem and all that stuff and that just all the crazy places I put
myself into and all that stuff.
And you know,
the crowds have really been reacting to it really well,
man.
I'm really impressed.
Like,
you know,
the comments I'm getting on stage.
This is something
you've done.
This is the first time you've done this.
I've been,
yeah.
And how many years you've been doing standup now?
15.
So,
um,
within like 14 years in is when you started getting this change?
Yeah,
man,
I,
you know,
it was a combination of like,
I'd start talking about something and then like,
you know,
three months later I'd see everybody talking about it and not that they're
taking from me,
just,
you know,
it's in the,
the,
the air.
So I'm like,
ah,
I want to do something different.
So I'm like,
I got all these crazy stories of my life,
you know,
that I just never talked about on stage.
And just getting to the place where I'm comfortable with being honest about,
you know,
all the crazy shit that happened to me and you know,
and just going on stage and see now reaction,
even if it doesn't get a laugh necessarily.
And it does,
it gets some of the stuff's real real,
you know,
it just builds this kind of credibility with the crowd that th the,
the goal with me on other stuff,
like it's a vulnerability but it's also you being a real person as opposed to a
guy putting on a show and putting on the shows like the armor that you throw up
when you first started doing stand up,
you know,
I had a breaking point the other day where,
is that the store and I was just watching a bunch of funny comics go up but
nobody was being real on and I,
I'm,
I'm not taking anything away from them because there was some really funny young
comics coming up that I really enjoy,
but I just found with comedy,
everybody wants to hear what they already know.
They want to really laugh.
Like it's gotten so much about relate-ability to the point,
you know,
that it's,
I just feel like it's like people want to,
people want to hear premises about stuff we all already agree upon and I just
don't want to do that stuff.
So I've been really breaking through and it can get,
it could be a hard place when you're doing this.
Really.
Okay.
But is that,
is it that people want that or is that's what they're being fed?
Well,
I think they're being fed because that's what they see most comfortable about.
Or that's what gets the biggest reaction.
That's all it is.
It's what it's with gets the biggest reaction.
So people do it because they want to get that reaction.
Right.
So you start getting that,
you know,
hey man,
you remember when you were in school and you know you're right.
A No.
Do you like me check yes or no?
Yeah.
People remember that.
Exactly.
So it's not even really that funny,
but it's very relatable.
Very relatable.
But that's not,
I mean it's also so sometimes it's funny,
I mean sometimes it's a real moment that someone's trying to recall from.
I know what you're saying though.
I know that that the thing where you're,
you're seeing a lot of like jokey joke type shit and you're like,
you're longing for Richard Pryor type bags.
You wrong longing for someone to go up there and just take it to another level,
which is why like I,
you know,
after a long time of resisting the late night spots at the comedy store,
I very much embrace them now because there's a lot more room for me just to
experiment.
And if I fail,
I fail.
If it goes well,
goes well and bub.
But when a hits,
it's like it's gold.
Yeah.
Those 10 rule,
10 people rooms,
you know,
it's like one o'clock in the morning and you finally get on stage and they've
seen everything.
If you can make those motherfuckers laugh blood from a stone,
you got something right.
And it's like running with weights on.
I uh,
I was doing the main room,
you know,
I've been blessed,
I've been gigging law on the road,
but I've been a,
you know,
I'll do a couple of weekends at the comedy store and I,
I get the last spot in the main room,
which is where I can do like an hour if I want to.
And,
and just last week it was a great crowd.
By the end of the night,
I'm going up.
Usually my Saturday spot is Sunday,
so I'll go up around like 1245 and the crowd was still there and they were
great.
But right when I walk on the stage,
these two dudes in the front row just jumped me.
You know,
they're just trying to heckle me,
ray right out the gate and I'm,
I'm very blessed.
I've been doing comedy long enough that I'm real,
I'm dead on the inside,
you know,
it's like Burntwood at this point.
Yeah,
there's no real reaction.
You're getting me.
So everything you thrown at me is a waste and I'm just going to hit you with
everything.
So I mean,
I'm just hitting these dude.
Damn,
the crowd is going nuts.
I mean,
just going pause,
break at like at like 1245 at night,
12 boom,
boom,
boom.
This guy,
I don't know,
I just say something.
I go,
where's your wife?
He goes at home.
I'm like,
yeah,
buried in the backyard and the place goes nuts and he just turns,
he's like,
really?
Motherfucker.
Really?
And he just starts going nuts.
He gets up.
He tried to grab his drink and throw it at me.
His friend grabs his arm,
stops it.
So he starts walking out and man this dude grabs a chair and tried to throw it
at me on stage and luckily his friends got it cause it was going to hit somebody
in the front row.
But I just get this weird reaction out of these people.
They try to like her.
My store though to the store is,
I had two people throw drinks at me at the store.
One guy threw a bottle of water and me and one guy threw a glass at me.
Yeah and you got dark,
dark,
dark place man.
First of all there's zero crowd control.
They're all comedians have to do their own crowd control and you have to like
kick people out.
The only guy who used to kick people out was Harris.
Pete,
crazy Harris.
Pete.
I had more,
I've had more people were moved from the comic store than any other place I've
ever played ever.
It was so bad that,
and it would fuck with everybody.
So like there'd be such evil moments there that I would buy the entire room
dramas that I did that several times.
I remember that because it was like,
look,
you know,
we're all in this together.
I'm not trying to make him money here just so you can't be an asshole.
All the door guys look like they're in some email band that has keyboardist and
triangles and it's just like,
it's like death cab for Cutie is security for the Er.
I'm like,
Yo Dude,
who's securing Yoo Hoo man.
Tight pants and knit skinny jeans and it can have sold too low crying.
You know,
it just like,
it's crazy.
So I mean I've had a couple instances of that,
man,
I just don't have security there.
They really don't have security.
Not Real security.
I just don't know why they just don't get the,
you remember Dublin's had that big black security guard?
I see black,
you have to mention that.
Yeah.
Well cause was I called them deep space.
He was so big and black.
It was,
I've never seen a human being with this bigger hands in my life.
That's the guy you need when you need something.
The comic store doesn't have anything.
I mean,
do they have any security?
Nothing.
Is there a one guy who's like a big guy who's trained in the arts?
Don Lewis was last of the Badass door guys.
He was this guy who with this comic who just knew like karate at a black belt.
Karate and was a big yoke dude too.
Yeah,
the Houston,
the day he used the date.
That's like six eight basketball player.
That's a good size.
Yeah.
For for gladiator baby.
Alright.
Don Lewis and some six eight white chick.
It would be great,
but I've seen taken on three dudes at one time.
Yeah,
you have to at
that place.
Sometimes you have,
they're all drunk though.
By the time you get in a fight with somebody at the comedy store,
you usually,
they're beyond hammered,
but Dunkin brought it up.
It's like,
how do you feel when you're the guy that goes after the comedian,
like the guy just trying to make you laugh and have a good time.
You go after him and tried to physically assaulted and it's like,
what is that?
Well it's also Hollywood.
Part of it is Hollywood itself because you get a disproportionate amount of
people who think they deserve way more attention than they're getting.
Like this is the place where they congregate.
This is the flow.
This is the light that draws the malls.
This is the place.
So they come here and one of the things that they want to do is prove that
they're better than everybody else.
You ever talked to someone who's like a really weak comedian?
It's sort of just starting out and like,
you know,
we're going to fucking own this town.
Did you ever see that movie?
Um,
uh,
overnight over here overnight.
It's a fucking brilliant movie about this very thing.
It's about a guy who is the director of boondock saints who wrote and directed
Boondock Saints and they produced this movie where they initially,
when they started following him,
he had just gotten this huge development deal cause he wrote the script.
Harvey Weinstein bought it.
They bought the bar where he worked in as a bartender and now it's his bar and
this whole thing and he's overnight success.
Okay,
well you watched this guy like become like the most bloated asshole because of
all the success that he's having and all this adulation and is getting,
he believes his own hype and tailspins and the whole thing is,
it's really fascinating to watch.
Really,
really fascinating to watch cause it guy becomes just a fucking asshole for no
reason.
You know,
when I used to work at a crunch gene Simmons wife used to go work out there and
she was talking to me about fame and she said,
what's the name of the lead singer kiss?
Uh,
Paul Stanley.
She said,
Paul Stanley told her that fame doesn't change you.
Fame just amplifies whoever you are by a thousand times.
Well this guy just decided that he was Billy Badass and he was the baddest
mother fucker when a fucking own this time there was all that.
They'd never seen a fucking group of talent like us.
We're a triple threat were the,
you know,
it was all this,
like it wouldn't be like,
Hey,
I think we're going to have careers,
we're going to be successful.
We're lucky.
We got chance to make a good film.
I'm really thinking we would make a good film.
It wasn't the end of that.
It was all we're going to fucking dominate.
We're going to own,
we're going to take over this town.
And um,
the whole,
it's a fascinating piece on watching the reaction to this guy.
Like he gets huge and all this,
you know,
he has all this arrogance and then it all implodes on them and you get to see
like the,
the,
the aftermath of it.
And it's a really interesting psychology or psychological sort of a,
uh,
like a profile.
Like it's,
it's an,
it's an interesting documentation of a process.
The process of hitting unfathomable heights,
of winning the lottery basically.
Yeah.
And that's,
you get that a lot like onsets.
Like you hear that a lot about what you'll hear it about certain actors,
it's scream and everybody on the sat,
you know,
where's my fucking water and this,
like throw scripts.
It like some,
I don't want to say who it was,
but she threw her coke in the face of the executive producer on my gut.
If you fuck your wife the way you,
right,
it's no wonder why you're getting a divorce.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Don't you think that has to do with how early almost you get it?
No,
I think it's just some people,
just the pressure.
First of all,
the pressure of being on like,
like some shit,
like let's say like,
okay,
let's go with a home improvement.
When home improvement was the number one show in the country,
the pressure must be madness.
It must be madness.
Like the reason why Charlie Sheen cracks like that,
don't you think?
Part of that is the pressure of just being Charlie Sheen.
Just the pressure of being on it's gigantic fucking hit Sitcom and everywhere
you go people are following you with cameras and just want to do coke.
Yes.
Want to go fucking Tracy [inaudible] was there a lot of pressure when you were
doing like a fear factor that will read it?
No,
not well,
there's definite a lot of pressure,
but it wasn't the same thing cause I wasn't really that famous.
It was a day.
It was like fear factor was famous.
I was just the host.
It's like,
you know like the guy who was a host of survivor.
What's his name?
Greg.
Jeff.
Jeff Probst.
Yeah,
When you watch Jeff probes,
like you don't think like,
Oh,
this is Jeff [inaudible].
It's like,
oh,
there's that guy who's survivors,
survivors.
So fear factor was the big show.
I was just the host.
The host has not only being Charlie Sheen,
that's a different level kind of psychosis.
Can't go anywhere without people going,
oh shit,
Charlie Jane,
Yo man,
I like rocks too.
He's got that right kind of fame I talk about and onstage where it's like he's
above it.
Meaning like no matter what he does,
we're cool with it.
I mean the guy locked the porn star in the bathroom after smoking crack and got
a huge TV deal with FX.
Anybody else that's taken them down by,
he's just at that level where it's like he's above it.
I mean he's got a new movie coming out.
I like him.
I liked those kinds of,
it's not,
it's not that he's above it.
He owns it.
That's who he is,
who he accepted.
The real problem is when someone pretends to be something they're not.
If someone pretends to be like a Ted Haggard type dude,
pretends to be this very pious religious leader who was trying to show people
the way.
Meanwhile he's smoking meth and getting gay hookers.
That's,
that's what people have a problem with.
It's not smoking meth and gang gay hookers.
Cause if,
you know,
if George Michael did it and it was just like honest about it,
like look,
I got a lot of money.
I really liked math and I like hookers and how the big boys,
they know what they're doing.
They know what to do.
We're having a good time here on your shit.
Yeah,
there's no problem.
Nobody has a problem with male prostitution.
Everybody's trying to stop prostitution,
but nobody puts any effort whatsoever to stopping male prostitution.
There's no campaigns.
There's no billboards.
There's fucking a lot of counseling to stop prostitution on the female side,
we see the terrible,
these girls are getting used.
This is terrible.
They're being victimized and degraded.
Nobody cares about the boys.
They did not care.
Those guys are sucking dicks all day long for cash.
Nobody cares.
It all because no one's looking out for men.
No one's looking out for men in this country.
You remember fat Eddie that you hang out at the comedy store?
A Mexican guy,
great guy.
It was his birthday and like everyone's buying him shots and it kind of goes
along the lines like everybody's protecting women.
You can't protect women enough no matter what.
Like if a woman gets just shit face,
you're like,
you don't have to do this.
You don't have to do this.
Listen,
no,
go home.
Listen,
we're worried about you.
You're too drunk.
Something bad's going to happen.
Dude.
Eddie's doing shots.
He's so drunk.
He's like,
I want to go to La.
Well,
I forget the name of the nightclub,
which after hours,
so we'll go there.
Nobody's like,
Eddie,
don't do it.
Where like you us to drop you off by yourself.
He's like,
yeah,
the guy's throwing up on the side of the car.
Nobody cares.
Nobody cares at all.
Eddie might die in the dumpster.
Yeah.
Nobody cares about male porn.
Nobody cares about male prostitution.
Nobody's looking out from men.
Period.
I got called a men's rights Dodo,
Mra Dodo by this chick.
It was,
we're talking about like someone was,
the tweet has something to do with feminism and someone called me a male rights
Dodo and I was like,
what does that even mean?
I had to look up Mra,
it's male rights advocate or male rights activists.
And I was like,
wow.
So someone who's a feminist can make fun of someone who's a male rights
activist.
That's hilarious.
Like just that,
that you would do that like a cross the board.
Massive generalization.
Male rights average.
That's like saying no.
Men Don't need any more help.
Like,
oh no,
no,
we're not going to allow that.
No,
we want a feminism.
But no help for men,
like as if there aren't some crow Raisie divorce laws.
Everybody's hard cores.
Ridiculous,
brutal,
terrifying divorces where the men were essentially targeted,
targeted,
roped in,
sucked in scammed and d and no one's looking out for those guys.
I can't,
knowing there's,
it's almost acceptable in this country for women to try to get pregnant by
famous guys.
Like it's an acceptable practice that will listen and they say,
Lou [inaudible],
she,
she should know better.
He should know better.
Maybe he should.
You're right.
Maybe you should,
but it's not cute to support what's essentially criminal behavior.
If someone,
someone's doing that,
it's criminal behavior.
I you know it,
I know it.
It's kind of weird.
You know,
a great example,
what you're talking about is like anytime you hear a story about a woman cutting
a man's privates off,
you hear women laughing about that constantly.
I don't know about that.
I've never heard a woman,
our girls joke about it,
that they think it's hilarious.
Maybe a really dumb ones that you're hanging around with who I choose to hang
out with.
But you hear people laugh about that.
If it went the other way,
no buddy.
It would be like,
dude,
that's not cool.
I agree.
There'd be way more outrage if a guy cut off a woman's pussy,
like cut it out,
scooped it out,
which there should be outraged but it should be outraged both way.
I mean the cut off a mans genitals and like put it in a blender is like
horrific.
It is horrific.
That lady was really evil and whether she was a man or a woman,
that's just someone being evil to a person.
And that's kind of my point.
It's like,
why wouldn't you be a male rights advocate?
What about that guy that got arrested for rape?
Did four years in jail and it turned out that the girl was lying and now she has
to do two months and she gets to do it on the weekends.
We talked about it the other day.
It's a,
it's a terrible case.
This poor man,
he was just the neighbor and the girl got caught watching pornography by her
mother.
So she concocted this story that she was sexually assaulted and she said that
the story just got bigger and bigger and bigger until it spiraled out of
control.
We talked to a guy on Greg Fitzsimmons show the other day who was accused
falsely accused of rape and he went to jail for six years before the woman
finally we're Canton.
He has zero repercussion.
You never got a dime from the state.
All he got was in typology.
The woman never did a day of time and it was a woman who he just got drunk with
and she didn't want to tell her boyfriend that she cheated on him.
So she made up a story about getting raped.
Famous others,
a football player who just got on Seattle.
Yeah,
it was in jail for five years.
He was going to be like a five star athlete at USC.
Yeah,
and the same is the same situation.
There's no repercussion if you're not a male rights advocate in those instances.
You're not a human,
you're not a humanist.
You don't care.
You care about women more than you care about the human race as a whole.
And the human rights is a whole,
absolutely.
Women need to be protected.
But guess what?
So do everyone.
So does every baby,
so does every adult.
So it was a young boy.
When a boy is five,
do you protect them?
How about 10 how about 20 it's 20 is where you stop.
That's ridiculous.
We're human beings and that's what you're dealing with is someone lying and
ruining someone's life.
And that can happen on both sides and you shouldn't eat the idea that you could
do like make fun of someone who's like,
look y'all for men's rights.
That's so gross.
If someone made fun of Feminists v the values and ideas of the true values,
ideas of equality in terms of law and employment,
nondiscrimination,
all those things.
If someone actually made fun of that just because they didn't like women,
that would be disgusting.
It would be disgusting and misogynistic.
But a woman can say that like male rights dodo or male rights advocate dummies
like that.
Did the completely dismiss the idea that there should be someone looking out for
men's rights.
But the idea is the problem is who's going to come forth and say,
we need to change those laws?
Who's going to come forth and say,
listen,
if you,
if you wanted acute falsely accuse someone of rape,
you have to go to jail for the exact amount of time that you put in prison.
That great that you should you absolutely.
Why wouldn't that be?
That only seems logical because they're not looking out for the human race
they're looking at for team vagina first.
Yes.
And they will even say that so many women are victimized that,
you know,
men should have to take the hit every now and then.
False accusations are acceptable as long as we limit the amount because there's
so they pale in comparison to the amount of women that are raped.
That's sort of maybe true,
but it's not.
It's not.
It doesn't make them any less bad.
I am still really bad and it fucks up the entire positive side of it.
Right.
It fucks up the entire pro woman side of it.
If you're willing to ignore the fact that a guy is unjustly victimized.
Yeah.
I was talking,
I had Tom like is some my pops and naughty show podcast and um,
he,
you know,
he got in a lot of trouble because he would give out the names of the victims in
these sexual stories when the stories coming out that they weren't being honest.
And you know,
I personally don't think any name in a sexual assault case should be put out
until a final verdict comes out.
I don't know if that's realistic,
but I mean,
especially in today when anybody can final verdict,
like this guy's case where he's in jail for four years,
he could have eased.
I mean he was essentially labeled as a rapist for four years.
I mean,
when is it okay to talk about it then when it turns out four years later that it
wasn't,
I agree with that.
I mean,
personally I would like nobody's name to be put out at all because again,
you could find out later on that they are innocent.
But I mean,
just the accusation towards a man,
TMZ,
we'll run with it.
If you're somewhat famous,
they'll say your name bright lights everywhere and alleged victim and you never
hear the name.
And I understand a point of that because you don't want,
you want women to come forward and not be afraid that their names can be
splashed everywhere.
But let's not put the guy's name out until we actually know something down the
line.
You know,
it's like,
it's interesting,
but when you're in a position like say if you're a famous basketball player or
something along those lines,
like there's no innocent until proven guilty,
there's accused them and then let them try to figure out how to exonerate
themselves that it happens very often and a lot of the times it's just people
that are crazy that are making things up.
You know,
a lot of people don't know that Mike Tyson story.
When Mike Tyson went to jail for rape,
did you know that the girl who accused him of rape also had a false accusation
of rape that she had to drop a year before that she had made up a rape story a
year before that?
Like this wasn't a new trick for her.
And I'm not saying that,
you know,
I don't know what happened or what didn't happen,
but Mike Tyson is incredibly honest about his background.
Like what he did wrong,
what he did right,
how he was feeling,
why he did the things he did.
And he maintains his day that he did not rape because one man show at the
pantageous.
It was phenomenal to say about that.
What did he say about the way that he didn't do it?
To this day,
he never did it.
He has no reason not to lie about it right now.
He's like,
I'm being honest about everything else.
I have no reason to lie right now.
I believe him and he went to jail for that.
And I'm not saying that it wasn't,
you know,
like Mike Tyson was out of control.
Not saying it wasn't a case where there was a guy who was just like scaring the
fuck out of people.
He was,
he looked,
you know,
put yourself in his shoes,
listen to his explanations of his life and you kind of understand where he was
coming from.
I mean,
I,
I think for sure it was a very,
very aggressive man.
But also for sure,
like how,
how aggressive could he have been that that is okay?
I mean,
how aggressive is it a B?
Cause he is he scary so it's okay to make up a lie about it.
I'm like,
when is it okay?
It's not,
it's never okay man.
But to this day that happened,
he went to jail and he's not the only guy.
It's happened to many people.
It is,
it's definitely a,
you know,
one way towards one group than the other and it's this horrible man.
I mean,
you're ruining people's lives.
It doesn't have to be,
that's the real problem.
I don't think it has to be only the people that,
you know,
the,
like the,
the female,
the weaker sex are the ones in the weak,
weaker physically are the ones that get the,
you know,
the get the compassion.
It should be,
everybody should have compassion for term for women who are sexist against men.
It's like miss stretch knee or something.
It's like,
I forget the name of the word,
but there's a label for it.
It's silly everybody,
man,
I liked everybody.
I really am.
If they're nice,
right?
100% if you treat people like a human being,
I'm totally open to you and I get it that women have to deal with a lot of
Douchey guys.
I totally get it.
I get,
I've been a Douchey guy.
My my life.
I think we all have trying to figure out who the fuck you are and you're 17 or
18 or what have you growing up.
Maybe you're angry,
maybe you know,
maybe somebody catches you on the wrong day.
We've all been wrong thing.
It's part of like learning how to communicate with people,
so I can imagine being a woman being pursued by a bunch of asshole,
aggressive shitheads.
I could tell,
I mean it was never that,
but I could get that.
I understand that.
I get why you would think that guy's disgusting.
If somebody raped you.
I get why you would hate all men.
I totally get it.
I totally get it,
but we're not all the same.
Like no one's all the same.
There's nice women,
there's nice men,
there's nice people.
There's people that enjoy each other's company on both sides and both sexes.
And we have to unite as a,
as a race against Shitty,
angry,
nasty behavior.
I can will be great with Your v victimizing people.
The,
all that stuff is the real issue.
It's nothing to do with whether it's women to men or men to women.
It's gross on both sides.
Scary on both sides.
A woman that's willing to poison her husband and killed him is just as scary as
a man who beats his wife to death.
They're just,
they're both monsters.
They're terrifying people there.
They,
they may both as dangerous as the other ones.
Sometimes you see like these sentences were like a man and woman committed
crime.
The guy gets life,
the woman gets like three weeks in jail.
You know why girls turn on?
The boy wasn't.
My idea is motherfuckers crazy dragging me.
Snitches get stitches.
Did you see this?
Um,
there's an article about this woman from a real housewives of New Jersey.
Do you know this?
She wrote a book kind of a housewife.
Is She on trial?
No.
Well,
there's that one too.
She basically,
uh,
says rape is okay.
What?
Yeah,
she's a,
her Melissa Goriga supports marital rape.
In her book.
What?
She talks,
she wrote a book about her hot marriage and,
um,
it's hilarious shit because they take all these passages and her husband is just
a savage.
He's this,
he's this Guinea with shaved head who wears leather pants.
Okay.
Right there.
You're,
you're,
you're in trouble.
And the leather pants or shady shit.
You see him.
I mean,
look,
ladies,
that's a savage.
All right.
Look at the size of that guy.
That's just how it goes.
And the,
it's,
it's hilarious reading the book.
And I was reading it from a feminist site,
which was really particularly fascinating because they were fucking furious.
They were so mad.
You know,
he says big meathead dude.
And apparently he just bangs or like a drum and he doesn't accept no,
he called cave man.
Fucking,
yeah,
he cave man.
Fuck her,
but she looks super happy.
Yeah,
I was having the conversation.
I go to the dog park,
I got a pit bull and there's a bunch of other comics who have pit bulls and a
bunch of female comics came up with their pimples was dog park and all they were
talking about was dick from the moment they got there to the moment they left,
it was a conversation about Dick and how they're planning Dick and all this
stuff and they were talking about this one guy.
She's like,
should I fuck them?
I'm like,
yeah,
let him just cave man.
Fuck it.
Just like knuckle drag primate.
Fuck you.
And it's like let it happen because that's what you want.
You see these girls with these emails and he's skinny jeans and these guys
crying like that's not it.
You need a nice cave man.
Fuck some girls,
some girls don't want that.
Sam Tripoli.
The point is,
some girls do and everybody's mad at this girl because she likes it.
She likes to get grill fuck by the savage dude and people think it's horrible.
It's terrible.
She likes to like give him to his requests.
She likes to have dinner ready for him or he gets pissed and everybody's like,
this guy's an asshole.
You don't have to marry him.
Okay,
she's just telling you,
but promise.
She's giving advice and the guy writes in the book to listen.
Listen to this man.
I know you think your woman is it.
The type of wants to be taken,
but trust me,
she is.
Every girl wants to get her hair pulled once in a while.
If your wife says no,
turn around,
rip her clothes off.
She wants to be dominated.
Yo.
Women don't realize how easy men are.
Just give us what we want.
That is hilarious.
That's really funny,
man.
Some people are in the roleplaying.
I love that role playing.
I love that cosplay.
I think that's awesome.
If a man comes home,
there's no dinner on the table and his wife was on the phone watching TV or on
the computer ignoring him,
he won't feel respected.
That's what did you expect?
It's real housewives of Jersey.
Yeah.
It's what works for them.
That's,
that's the point.
It works for them.
God Damn it.
What's your problem?
People hate it.
Well,
they hate it because it sends out a message to other girls.
You know that they have to tolerate that shit and you might not want it.
Some people do.
Yes.
I mean,
it's not my style.
I wouldn't want if I was a woman,
either eight,
fuck your wife ain't fuck your wife.
It's not even just a park.
And I think he said rape.
I by no means no unless,
unless you're role playing.
But no means now it seems like rape to hey,
it's just hilarious.
It's uh,
it's,
it's really interesting.
There's real passionate sex and this maintenance sex,
you need them both for healthy marriage.
Maintenance.
Sex keeps the wheels greased,
the lines of communication open and the fights to a minimum.
It's basically,
it's basically controlling a zoo.
Like,
yeah,
like her,
her,
the way she handles being married is like being a zookeeper.
Occasionally.
You got to feed the monkey out and feed the animals.
Got to keep the,
the animals have to be treated with respect.
You know,
nothing wrong with that.
Hey,
if it works for you.
Yeah.
She fucking seems really happy.
If she's happy,
I,
you know,
it should be like,
this works for me.
You might want to try it.
It's really interesting man.
It's really interesting.
It's really interesting because uh,
you see how other people react to this person's life and they're angry.
You know,
it's,
I kind of,
I think it'd be more funny than anything,
but I guess the,
a site like,
like these feminists science,
I guess their point is that the sends a really bad judge.
I've always felt like PR,
there's a difference between progressives and liberals.
Liberals are really open minded to all all thoughts.
I don't know if you can be open mind to everything,
but you pretty much open mind to different lights.
I feel like progressives are a little more skewed way to the left kind of way.
The neo cons,
a skewed way to the right where they have a certain vision of how the world
should be.
It's more of an idealistic view of the world where it's like I,
it's like Rosie O'donnell versus Howard Stern.
I feel like Howard stern and what he represents is more of a a liberal base
where he's like,
he'll make fun of everybody.
Whereas Rosie O'donnell has a certain view of how she should see the world and
if views progressive,
you know like feminism and all that stuff and I'm open minded to everybody.
I don't care if you're straight gay or whatever you're into man,
woman,
whatever.
If you're a cool person,
I I'm down with it.
Yeah.
I think the idea of progressive is just that.
It's just like anything else.
Call yourself a Republican,
call yourself a Democrat,
call yourself a liberal,
call yourself a conservative.
The reality is you who you are is probably a gigantic spectrum of different
things and to narrow it down to one or the other and to one other people to be
like you is insane.
Like idealism.
If somebody reads this and they have a problem that this woman lives like this
personally,
then if she likes it,
what if she likes it?
Is that okay?
Like I was looking at this Twitter page the other day and it was some crazy lady
who likes to get ball gagged and she's like,
there's a smile behind his ball gag and that's,
she has,
she's shown her rope marks on her arms and she's like in a bondage and shit like
that.
But that's what she's into and isn't real feminism like allowing all the full
spectrum of of human behavior in,
in,
in the,
the female mind,
you know,
just like in the,
I mean it's a fucking,
it's ridiculous.
This girl likes this and this keeps him happy.
It's like,
well,
it's like when they gave Palestine democracy and they got mad when they voted
for who they vote for.
It's like you can't say,
hey,
here's the freedom to vote and then get mad who they vote for it.
You know?
It's like if you have freedom to choose and you choose something I like doesn't
mean that you didn't use it.
Right.
It's just the way it is.
There's also people have to acknowledge that Italians are not regular humans.
They just have to,
okay.
They have to to totally different type type of human being that Italians are
different than everybody else.
It's a completely different thing.
And what came from the Romans,
they there,
there's thousands of years of savagery behind these people.
All of a sudden they start making spaghetti and meatballs.
You think everything's going to calm the fuck down gray.
It's not.
It's not a normal person.
Right.
There's,
there's a big difference between the savagery that lies in the Italian DNA and
your average waspy type check.
You know who went to Columbia and where's Birkenstocks and he's really tired of
assholes like this,
promoting this kind of bullshit.
Right?
Male Petronas,
the saddle,
you know,
what is that?
It's a different type of human.
That's what it is.
Okay.
She needs to get kb.
I look,
there's no way you can tell me that Oprah Winfrey and Shaquille O'Neal have the
same thoughts.
They do not Rosie O'donnell and Shaquille O'Neal.
Do they have the same thoughts?
Does Michael Jordan think like Katie Couric?
No.
The fuck he does not.
Okay.
We're different.
Goddammit.
And what works for you might not work for them.
Works for them.
Might be awesome in their world.
I always find that people want a world that plays to their strengths and they
want to outlaw a place of their weaknesses.
Yes.
You know,
they want a world that they are their king and then it get rid of the people
that make me play to my weaknesses and it's just,
it's still obvious when you see that,
when you know,
ideally it should be like everybody should be allowed.
If you treat your fellow human being nice,
you should be able to be who you want to be and do what you want to do.
You know,
it's like the naughty shows a great example of there's some female comics who
will not do the naughty show cause they don't like that there's an a porn star
here and there.
Even though I put more females up on my show that most people,
I put more female comedians up on my shelf than most people do.
I find female comics very funny.
I've the ones that I like,
there are some who go in there and just crush that room,
but there's some women who will not even get on the stage because they're just
think it's the,
it's degrading.
Yeah.
Degrading to women.
I understand that thinking I know where they're coming from.
I don't agree with it.
I think,
you know,
it's,
it's very possible to be a porn star and,
uh,
be a feminist if you really love sex and you really,
I mean,
I'm not saying that every girl who does it feels that way,
but you could be,
you could be someone who really loves sacs.
It really loves being like a,
you know,
an exhibitionist and wants to fuck on films and a brand,
almost a man's able to do it and we don't go looking to save him.
But if a woman does it,
like,
okay,
just,
I mean this is just throwing it out there,
just trying to objectively look at the full spectrum of human behavior and
saying it is possible that it's not degrading for that woman.
It is possible if it's just sex.
I think it comes from the fact that there was a notion one time that women don't
like sex,
that women only give into our sex cause we want it and they really want nothing
to do with it.
But the reality is they love sacks as much as men love sex.
And I've been reading about all these girls pulling guns out on dudes trying to
have sex with them to hear about the Denny's waitress who robbed the guy
gunpoint,
took his wallet that made him have sex with her friend.
Oh God.
Gunpoint.
Yeah.
He might have had a good time that night.
I don't know,
man.
How ugly is that friend?
Did you need to pull a gun?
How did he get it hard?
And that's what's really quick.
Yeah.
That's gotta be a rough one.
Guy's a bad mother fucker.
Get hard with a gun in his hand.
Yeah.
I think I'm Quintin Tarantino.
There's a lot of people that are really emphasizing,
uh,
things that would benefit women,
but there's a lot of them that do think that men should be able to be with
whoever the fuck they want.
And we should be able to choose the choose that mean there's people that you get
along with it.
I wouldn't,
I get along with it.
You wouldn't,
it's just a part of life where weird pieces and we don't fit together like
puzzles.
You know,
sometimes you find people and together they work,
right?
It doesn't mean it seemed to make sense and yeah,
they might be broken,
but guess what?
You're a little broken too stupid.
You're not the perfect person.
You know buddies where this one article this woman was talking about,
she,
she posted over hate tweets.
All the people that tweeted her and they were about various subjects,
all kinds of different things that they disagreed with her.
They should insulting her and shitting on her.
She said,
but she says,
you know what?
These people all have in common.
They all hate women.
It's like,
no,
no.
They don't hate women.
They don't like you because people don't like you.
You can't say they hate women.
That's the biggest cop out of all times.
That's trying to control the thought and stopped the conversation.
That's like the low blow,
like Oh okay conversation show you hate women think we're done.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
And the idea that because someone hates you,
they hate everything with a vagina is a ridiculous and especially when they're
being very specific about what you said,
that's stupid.
That doesn't mean they hate every woman.
And that idea that you're going to get back up from every person with a double x
chromosome on the planet because you said that is,
is a silly like parachute that people pull to try to stop everything.
It's control your thoughts.
It's ridiculous.
It's weak and it's hacky and it's tired.
It's a really weak minded way of approaching any sort of a discussion.
You know,
you could,
you could show about how angry these fucking people are about various ideas,
which is true.
The anger that you see on Twitter and on the Internet.
It's unbelievable.
Man.
There was,
there was a uh,
a thread today that I posted,
I posted it last night about climate change and it was just an article that I
read.
I think it was invite,
uh,
maybe it wasn't vice.
I'll,
I'll find out.
Cause I po,
I posted something advice about um,
the uh,
Pacific garbage patch and uh,
there was this thing on climate change and all I did was just put it up there
and the topic was nine things that or things that scientists are less sure of
than they are of climate change and all the sudden it,
my fucking,
it is on vice motherboard died vice.com.
All of a sudden my Twitter feed became this massive argument back and forth
between people that are in total denial that we're causing climate change.
These are the same scientist in the 70s.
So we're headed to an ice age.
Um,
no they're not.
Those guys are dead.
Okay.
That's 1970.
You dumped con to yeah,
that's a long ass time ago.
You think those fucking people are alive?
1970.
That's 43 fucking years ago.
You think those people are still alive?
It just is.
People react emotionally now instead of logically they don't digest what you're
saying and understand that it might be a different perspective.
It's not even emotional.
It's ideologically,
there's a left and a right and people on the left think that climate change is
been done by man and that we're accelerating it.
We need to do something and carbon tax and all this shit and people on the right
think it's just a ploy to get more taxes.
People on the rights say,
look,
you look at the trends,
the earth is warming and cooling.
It's been going on forever.
It's the way things have always been.
Oh well how come the last six years of showed a coon Trent and these all these
wacky motherfuckers that don't want to believe it.
They're not scientists.
They have real jobs.
There's people that are studying this 20 hours of fucking day every day of the
week and they don't really know what the fuck is going on.
And some Dick head with a regular job and reads the Wall Street Journal and
pretends he's a player in the stock market cause he day trades during lunch.
This dump fuck thinks he can tell.
You know,
he's one of those Weirdo right wing.
there's,
this is what's good for business,
this and a lot of them are broke.
That's what's really interesting about people that support big businesses and
they have right wing ideologies and a lot of them that would support these big
businesses are getting fucked over by the same businesses on the regular isn't
called the the lottery mentality where like,
yeah,
even though people are broke,
they're like,
I might win the lottery and then I don't want to pay taxes on that.
We're like,
well,
that,
that probably not going to happen.
Well,
there's also that people don't ever want to think that they're losers.
They always want to thank that to just winners who haven't won yet.
So even if their life is shit,
it keeps falling apart and they never get it right.
One day I'm gonna get it and when I do these fucking pukes in Washington,
I can't in a nickel,
these mother fuckers,
they don't work for Shell.
And you know,
what they're trying to do is to put the hippies to vote against your own
interests.
It's just so interesting.
Yeah.
This guy,
Seth Bronstein,
the Associated Press and science correspondent.
What he said was that the world's climatologists are now gearing up for
officially to officially put claim that they are 95% certain that humans are to
blame for global warning.
That 5% gap may seen large.
It is not in science,
nothing is 100% sure.
Not even a law of gravity and according to this Guy Borenstein there are a few
things that scientists or just as or less certain of then climate change and
they are one that cigarettes kill to the age of the universe.
Three that vitamins make you healthy and for that dioxin in Super Fund sites is
dangerous.
Wow,
that's la.
That's hilarious.
Also that string theory actually describes reality and that the rate of the
universe expanded after the Big Bang.
Those are,
uh,
those are other ones that the author has added a little less certain about this
author Brian Merchant.
So interesting article and it's,
it's a big point is that for whatever reason,
people that don't really know want to jump up and say,
look,
I am no fucking climate expert by any stretch of the imagination.
I,
I sort of get it,
but I also,
I know that there was,
I mean there's been ice ages without human intervention.
There's been the period when the dinosaurs were here.
It was a vastly different climate than we are experiencing right now.
We obviously had nothing to do with that.
That was an asteroid impact that changed our climate.
All that shit happens and it happens on a regular basis and it probably happened
12,000 years ago and it's probably what ended the last ice age.
But these people that pretend that they know that we're not causing some of it,
you're crazy.
Is it that you think that you could now get your news tailored to your views
instead of like everybody watching like four channels now?
There's such niche news channels that just play to what you want to hear so just
reinforces what you're saying.
Like there's no real f you don't hear the other side of the argument.
You only hear what you want to hear.
Well there's certainly that,
that's certainly an option.
At least it is right now.
You know,
I think one of these days there's going to be some sort of technology where you
could post something and it will immediately be bare verified as truth or,
or horse shit.
Like say if you,
Oh,
I'd love to see the horse shit symbol.
Well it's,
it seems like it should be able to,
like you should be able to post a statement and then have to put like an ass or
an I said it's just an idea.
Uh,
you know f maybe it's just that it's fiction or s a statement if you want people
to take you seriously.
So if you go with s and you believe this and then boom,
it calculates all of the known scientific data from peer reviewed sources and it
just gives you a pile of horse shit that sits underneath your post.
Oh,
this should be a graphic.
This,
this post has been shown to be horse shit.
And then is something that like would be really interesting.
Like it would stop a lot of like Internet debate,
like climate debate or this debate of that.
There's a lot of it.
You've got to Google Shit and you gotta find the post the posted up.
No,
that's bio source.
And it'd be nice if there was a,
and it will,
it will happen.
It's gonna happen.
Consumer reports,
no bias,
just boom,
no advertisements,
no nothing.
Peak in a,
which people on Twitter today were schooling me on Yelp,
some business orange because I love Yelp.
Yelp is such a great resource when you go somewhere,
like if you go like to a town,
you want to find out what the bad ass restaurant is.
For the most part it's super accurate.
But apparently two things that people,
uh,
showed me,
one,
which is kind of crazy,
is that Yelp actually writes reviews.
Like they have employees that even write bad reviews.
What?
Yes.
And that if you have some shitty reviews on your site,
they'll actually ask you if you want to get those moved and they can like move
them to the back price.
Yeah,
they charge you,
they charge you per month.
And it's a,
like these people were describing like being called like once a month by the
company.
And you know,
I mean,
I obviously this is one side of it and I would love to hear the ledge,
the Yelp site as well because like I said,
I use Yelp all the time and I really like it.
But it said there was another thing that 20% of all Yelp reviews are written by
page.
Shills.
Oh,
I mean,
you can see that on like iTunes comments and I mean like you can just,
there's computer programs who just like,
we'll make up fake like comments.
Well,
you know what else they're doing.
There's also people that are manipulating their iTunes a number,
especially podcast by re uploading the same episode by,
uh,
by they,
they,
there's some way that they manipulate the upload process.
I had a f uh,
Chris score was on my podcast and he was telling me about,
he knew he wouldn't name the names,
but he knows people who know how to manipulate it just so their rankings can go
up.
Yeah.
Well,
that's how you're ranking on no clue.
I just rankings go up by apparently the iTunes thing has to do with posts and
comments and it also has to do with downloads and also stay with new
subscribers.
And so people develop algorithms to kind of hack into this.
Allegedly,
allegedly this is alleged,
by the way,
this is not my thoughts,
this is according to another podcast or really was upset about it,
but he thinks that there's some shenanigans going on.
I'm sure there is.
Well,
did you hear about that guy that uh,
he was buying,
um,
buying Twitter friends,
you,
there's,
there's a service and as a comedian he admitted to buying Twitter friends.
And then last night he actually punched um,
a reviewer.
He was at a show.
Did you hear about this?
And I mean it really kind of fucking mild shit that this guy got stories about
that dude.
The guy punched him.
Oh yeah.
What's his name?
Uh,
whatever.
You don't need to,
I don't want to get sued,
but I wa I was actually on tour and they were telling me a story about punches.
You will sue you if story about him that uh,
he was famous then if they sue,
I'm not gonna tell store.
No he doesn't.
You
don't have to this,
he didn't say who the guy is.
Well what he you would do is like if he,
if he,
if you found out you were the same kind of comedian as him,
an ethnic group,
right.
He found it use the same time a comedian has and you got booked on this ethnic
group comedy night.
What do you would find out is he would call you up and he'd go,
Hey,
I got this other Gig that night.
It pays this.
Why aren't you do my show?
And you'd be like,
why are we got booked bum?
I are few more mind guys.
Okay,
so you on book that show,
he'll call them up,
get you booked on,
book himself in your spot.
And then when the show comes up I'll call you.
I'm go,
yeah,
the show got canceled.
I'm sorry.
And then go do your spot in your show.
Unless you've heard this firsthand.
I wouldn't say that cause that's I,
you just,
I just told me,
I just said it again.
Can we kill him?
Yeah.
I would never say no.
Yeah,
that shit come on and it goes live.
Go wide.
And that's how I've heard the story.
So he punched
guy in the face.
This guy who was a,
um,
uh,
I guess he's a a reviewer for,
what does he review for it?
Not the Huffington Post.
It was a,
I'll tell you right now.
He reviews for a Newsweek daily beast and hilarious.
That mean it's hilarious.
The Guy was,
uh,
you know,
he's telling a bunch of hacky jokes and so the dude talked about it on his
Twitter and he came up to him,
asked him if that was his name and just punches him right in the face and then
pushed him and then came back and punched him in the face again.
And what the guy said was really fucking mild.
This is what gets you to punch his,
the guy's name was funny until he dusted off as 2005,
Katrina jokes in a gratingly bad GWB impression.
That sounds like some,
some criticism that started off saying you were funny,
you're funny,
and then you did a shitty joke or you're funny until you started telling jokes.
And then he said he makes the umpteenth,
his umpteenth joke about how agents can't distinguish between letters l and r
election erection.
We get it.
That's it.
And then the next one is the guy just punched him in the face.
That's incredible.
The guy's name is Josh Rogan.
I N and no,
I'm not talking about this because his name is Rogan.
I'm talking about this because it's important you shouldn't get punched because
you say someone's socks.
Who by listening to Josh Rogan's tweets,
pretty much fucking socks.
And if the guy's not telling the truth,
I mean,
if he's,
you know,
if he made up these guys,
I mean,
this guy's tweets,
it would be one thing,
but we could read them,
you know,
we could read them and we could see exactly what he said that got him punched.
And it's pretty Goddamn mile.
Pretty Tame.
I mean,
there's,
you know,
there's
no hiding this.
It's not like he called me a coke and he says,
my mother's a whore.
No,
no,
no.
It says right there.
So if that's really how it went down,
we don't know how it went.
If I swung on everybody that criticize me on Twitter,
it'd be just one.
I'd be Bruce Lee taken.
I'm 90 dudes at one time we saw,
I was talking about with the climate thing is how God damn
angry people get on Twitter.
People were so angry and I don't think it's because of the words that they're
debating.
I think most of this anger is there are already on a short fuse because they're
not happy with their situation,
whether it's their relationship or their body or their job or their career or
all of the above.
There's whether it's,
you know,
whether there's something they did wrong or whether there's something they
haven't done right,
whatever it is.
I think people just inherently frustrated their position in life and there's a,
you know,
there's,
everyone is anonymous,
so it's like there's very little accountability.
It doesn't come back to you.
It only goes back to your page and it stops there.
That's why what a ESPN has done is now you have to log in with your Facebook
page because Facebook,
you have to use your real name.
They have to verify it's you,
and you have to use your real name.
So if you're going to comment somewhere,
you have to put your name on it.
Oh,
that's funny.
But ESPN makes you do that.
That sounds like bullshit to me.
I don't like that.
I do and I don't.
I like accountability,
you know?
Yeah.
But I don't think it takes away a lot of trolling.
If you're going to say something,
you're going to put your name on it.
Yeah.
And I guess it does.
If your rep,
if you're representing a company like ESPN,
they do have a very,
uh,
certain,
um,
reputation to uphold.
They got mad at me once.
Who?
ESPN.
Yeah.
I,
I said that,
uh,
I said that this dude,
Houston Alexander fights,
like he tried to rape his mother.
I'm sorry I said that,
but that's an old school gym expression.
Unfortunately,
as a a person who's trained in fight,
Jim's my whole life.
That's a a really common expression.
It doesn't seem like it is,
but it actually is.
It's,
especially in the east coast where I grew up in Boston.
That is,
I have heard that so many times in the,
in the description of a guy,
dude,
it's,
it's Disney man.
They,
they,
they uh,
suspended Tony Kornheiser because he said that one of the female reporters was
dressing like,
she's like 20 years younger and they,
he had to take a week off.
I mean it's because ESPN has had a lot of pro,
if you read their book,
they had a lot of problem with sexual harassment way back in the day.
So anything that comes even close to that,
it's like,
whoa.
It's just unfortunate when everybody has to,
I mean,
it's one thing if you're saying something that's shitty and,
but it's another thing to act like straight forward towards political
correctness because if I said he fights,
like he's trying,
he tried to kill his mother.
Everyone would have been fine with that.
You fight like he fights,
like he tried to kill his mother.
Everybody would have been fine like that,
but the sexual implications of rape or somehow or another off,
it's just too,
it's too much.
It's officer violence and sex.
I just looked at two totally different things.
Isn't it weird?
It is a movie and you see a dude kill 30 40 people.
But if they fuck and you see his penis going into her vagina,
people will explode.
The thing that they want to do all day.
Everybody wants a fuck.
This is what most people want.
If your hormones work,
you want this.
You want someone who wants to fuck you and the you want to fuck them and you
actually liked them and they actually like you and you,
you,
you guys both liked to fuck each other and you'd go at it.
That's what people want.
What do people not want to get killed?
They don't want to get killed,
but what can't you see?
Can't see people fucking what?
Can you see people getting guilt?
Why is that?
We're crazy.
We didn't,
we never hear about stories about Spri sexist,
peop people walking into the offices and just fucking having sex with everybody.
You never see that.
And I knew it was,
but you see a guy going crazy and shooting everybody.
Yeah.
Nobody goes to the neighbor,
the Navy Yard and sucks.
Everybody's fair.
Some chick like crazy,
crazy.
One of the tech socking rampage,
you know,
that is a really important point.
We have this weird desire for,
for violence in this country and even though in real life we love sax and we
want sex all the time.
You can't just blow people on TV.
He can't.
I mean,
if they,
if they show anything in the,
in the TV show,
it's a kiss and maybe you start pulling,
show his clothes off and then the fucking screen was black sex and the city
stuff.
It's like passion,
passion.
Next day,
laying in bed.
Could you imagine if there was a real incident where a guy came to like some
police station and just sucked everybody's Dick just gas the whole room,
pulls a pin,
throws it in their sleep and gas.
Everybody falls asleep.
They wake up and the video tapes of him just show him suck in every dick in the
place because he goes and he's there were unconscious.
These members have families and you just suck on her Cox.
He gives them all Viagra.
Ainley puts it in their ass,
crushes it up.
Crunch,
crunch,
crunch the Russian chick.
Yeah.
Who Law.
The guy walked into the the beauty salon and he goes,
fucker fucking who has that much telephone wire available to tie somebody up and
then just shelled Viagara in it for three days.
It's attitude to let her,
he's full of Shit.
It's nonsense.
He's full of Shit.
He fucked her.
Look.
I even,
I just think even if someone gave you Viagara,
if he didn't want to fuck them,
you probably wouldn't get hard.
It's the Viagra doesn't make you just get hard for no reason.
Just eat a Viagara.
Your Dick doesn't just get hard.
You have to get stimulated.
I don't know,
man.
I think where direction,
I think he's annoying.
He's probably just a dumb dude that wanted attention.
She make me six live as the worst Russian accent ever.
Fairly.
There you got a future in voiceovers?
I don't think I do believe in yourself.
I don't,
did you see that dude where they grew a nose on his face?
Yeah.
And that's the bad car accident.
He's got an host on his forehead.
Well he had a car accident and then he got a nose infection and then the middle
of this infection,
um,
his nose actually like,
you know,
like you,
you can get a necrosis,
you can get like a really bad skin infection and your tissue dies off and they
have to replace that tissue.
Like sometimes with a staph infections,
guys have to get,
um,
there's,
the dude knows,
right?
Yeah.
That's the growing,
well,
you know,
that woman who was on a time cover with her nose
cutoff,
do you remember that?
There's a time,
whatever it was a famous case of violence against women in Afghanistan.
She was given away.
It's sanely horrible.
She was given away as like,
as property is.
Like,
you know,
she,
they,
the parents owed money or something and they gave her away.
Oh my God.
You know,
having little girls,
man.
And the idea of that about giving your little girl way to someone who is so
horrific to me.
So impossible to even imagine.
I've been Afghanistan,
they are half ass backwards.
I'm sorry man.
Is Medieval Times over there?
How many times you go there?
I went there once and we uh,
we were actually there when the big prison break happened that kind of changed
the momentum of the board.
They,
they had this big inside job worth 300 extremists got out and it kind of changed
it and we couldn't leave right off the bat because of the whole thing.
But it happened while you were there.
Whoa.
Would that feel like it was scary,
man?
I mean it was scary things,
but you know,
it's like if I do usls man,
I would prefer to go into a war zone and irritating the troops.
I just,
they're very appreciative and you feel like you're doing something for him.
So I'd rather go into that then go,
I've done basis on like Guam where it just,
there's no,
and I'm glad there's no war going on there,
but it's just like they're just a base.
And they're okay with it.
But they're like,
yeah,
whatever.
You know,
but you go into some queue.
We went to a base called the Alamo cause it was so rounded by locals man.
And they were so thankful.
I mean they were totally a pre,
every joke just was this giant def jam laugh.
Why?
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Just huge laughter man.
I would much rather do that.
Wow.
That's really interesting.
Do you still do it?
You still go over this?
Did one,
we went to Bahrain.
Uh,
we're like all the missiles are in case I ran,
decides to,
you know,
get a little crazy.
Well that's the,
uh,
that's the place where Amber Lyon,
got fired from CNN or left CNN because of she uh,
did this detailed report on Bahrain and they turned it into like a tourist
piece.
Like you should visit Bob Rain,
beautiful downtown Bar rain.
It's weird when you go to all these places,
how much American culture is everywhere.
You know,
Aaron Cater use have a joke about that.
About how,
um,
you know,
like he goes in the Middle East,
do entertaining,
maybe like America is a paper tiger,
you know,
but what do you want?
Do you want KFC,
Yolanda?
Tgi Fridays.
And it's true.
You go there.
All of our stuff is everywhere.
Yeah.
Those big corporations,
it's like,
oh,
subway's a little Caesar's.
I mean,
who the fuck?
Where's the little fucking Caesar's?
It's in Bahrain,
dude.
Do you know that,
um,
subway is the biggest chain in the world now.
Bigger than Mcdonald's surpassed it.
Yup.
And then credible.
Yeah,
man.
I mean people like that fake meat,
Bro.
Is it fake?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
well alleged.
I know.
It's real me.
Get out of here.
I mean,
you could eat it,
but it's me.
What's here?
It's processed.
Of course it's processed.
Yeah.
Well,
if you want it preserved,
I love subway,
by the way.
I don't want this to be like an anti subway thing.
I eat that thing all day.
Buffalo chicken till I die.
I was in,
um,
Cheech and Eatsa,
uh,
go into the,
to see the Mayan Pyramids and we pass by this huge sign for Coca Cola,
a big billboard and the jungle for Coca Cola.
I was like,
this is so weird,
right?
Coca Cola in the middle of the jungle.
It's really strange.
So there's a whole thing that Mcdonald's had expanded as far as it could expand
that,
you know,
like these,
these fast food chains,
they make as much money on selling franchises as they do on selling burgers.
And the one thing was that they,
they had expanded everywhere they can and can't expand anywhere else.
Yeah.
There probably was no more spots where they could be and was viable.
But subway had a new niche.
People wanted to get thin like Jared.
Yep.
I just weird cause like in La,
like they,
they open,
they,
it's either chases triple A's or Starbucks there though.
Someday they'll open the Chipola in a chase bank that's in a Starbucks.
There's so many.
But the minute I leave la and I go somewhere,
I'm like,
where the Starbucks?
You told me that um,
when you were in Afghanistan they have Manlove Thursday man love Thursdays days
that real?
Yes.
They,
you saw it.
Well I didn't watch guys go but fuck in the mountains.
I didn't.
Let's say people told you,
man,
that shit.
Did people tell you about it?
I ask anybody who was on tour in who was on duty in Afghanistan,
ask them about man love Thursday.
They'd be like,
hey,
how'd you know about that is the only Thursdays though that gets Thursdays puff
fucking Thursdays.
So what does it mean Thursday everyone's allowed to be gay.
No,
it's,
they don't see it as gay.
They see it as like they see women are for procreation men or for fun.
Is that really true?
According to what I was told over there.
And you can go into the mountains and they just,
and they bought fuck each other and they're dirty too.
I mean just,
just the idea of thought.
Fuck.
It was a harsh,
dirty dude.
I mean like there dude.
I mean,
they tried to build,
like they tried to build these things for the pedestrians to walk up over the,
the road,
like a walkover.
They would just go in there and take dumps and then leave.
They didn't even use it to as a walkover like they do in Vegas.
You know when you're walking in Las Vegas Boulevard,
they have those pedestrian walkovers.
There's an article about it online.
It says Afghanistan's male soldiers are having sex with other guys,
but don't call them homos.
Well,
there was also something where like,
uh,
they were like their soldiers,
they would have a young boy who would have to service everybody,
check this.
And they had to tell the soldiers,
don't get upset about that.
But yeah,
don't get involved.
That's their custom.
Whoa.
Well,
we know their customers,
that the young girl that died,
she was sold away to marriage.
She was eight years old.
She died after having sex with a guy.
This,
listen to this.
Afghanistan's w w the,
the article is in Queerty,
um,
free of an agenda
except that gay one,
Queer D.
Dot com queer.
Like instead of Cordy.
Queerty how Ha Alex have were they,
when they got that domain nanny as I love,
I love the title to freaking agenda.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Um,
and it's talking about a,
it says Afghanistan's mail.
Sir soldiers have a sex,
have sex with other guys,
but don't call them homos.
And it says it's really interesting.
It says America's gay soldiers have unique struggle in their hands,
whether the hide or be open about their sexuality.
But Afghanistan's gay soldiers have a different battle.
Despite regularly having sex with other men and shunning women.
Many of these male soldiers refused to identify as gay,
which can get in the way of say,
preventing STDs.
You need only watched the CNN clip below where three gay American troops speak
of the need to repeal.
Don't ask,
don't tell,
has been repealed.
Now I believe to understand the difficulties of being gained.
The US armed forces,
you know,
oldest article is from man love.
Thursdays has its own post on urban dictionary.
It's the article.
It doesn't say where it's from here.
Unfortunately it doesn't say what year.
So it was before.
Don't ask,
don't tell was repelled.
So I don't,
hmm.
Repealed rather,
um,
for these Afghan soldiers.
However,
having sex regularly with other men is no big deal.
Just don't call them gay and unclassified study from military research unit in
southern Afghanistan.
That's a funny statement.
And unclassified study from a military research unit in southern Afghanistan
that's looking into gay sex details,
how homosexual behavior is unusually common amongst men,
among men in the large ethnic group known as Pash Dunes,
PA ash t you ends Pashtuns,
although they seem to be in complete denial about it.
What's a new unclassified study of past June meant Oh,
that's,
that's what the new,
uh,
unclassified study revealed these men admire.
Other men physically have sexual relationships with boys and shun women both
socially and sexually.
Yet they completely reject the label of homosexual.
The research was conducted as part of a long standing effort to better
understand Afghan culture and improve western interaction with the local people.
When you reach it like that and you read that,
you're like,
people are dying over there,
you know,
and you,
you think like the idea that they're going to try to change this.
You think about what they do with a marry off eight year old girls cut women's
noses off.
They,
they do this kind of shit.
Pretend they're not gay,
whether fucking each other and be homophobic at the same time.
It's absolute madness.
It's reality your way right away.
It's like custom made reality.
This is what they do.
This is how they figured out their way around it.
The pash doing men interpret the Islamic prohibition on homosexuality to mean
they cannot love another man,
but it doesn't mean they can't use men for sexual gratification.
What an interesting little gray area there.
There's a little fine print right there.
It's sort of like prostitution is illegal,
but if a girl is naked at a strip club and she rides your Dick and you come your
pants,
that's all good.
If,
if it prostitution's illegal,
but if I buy you dinner and then we have sex,
I spend the same amount of money on the date and then I have sex with you.
It's perfectly legal or paver,
their housing or something along those lines and just keep them on the payroll.
Like that was,
there was a,
um,
Kathleen Madigan was here and she lives in this certain part of Hollywood where
they have all these like really nice bungalows,
really cool small houses.
And she was like,
that's where the studio heads just to keep their mistresses,
they still like put them up in these houses.
I was like so common that there was a whole neighborhood,
if that's hilarious.
It's not.
Stop to think about that.
I mean,
if prostitution is illegal,
what's going on there?
Well there's that whole website,
a sugar daddy.com.
You know,
where a lot of,
uh,
you know,
young female ladies from Hollywood or on and it's guys with money looking for,
companionship.
That's a good place to get poisoned.
What do you mean?
If I was a check that was looking at Stila God's money and poisoned him,
that's where I'd look.
Go find your sugar down the old fashioned way.
Getting a sugar daddy on the Internet,
Jesus Christ,
whatever happened,
whatever happened to old fashioned interaction between your Tinder to people
looking at each other in the eyes that I need to know each other and me having
an understanding person to person.
It's really primal now.
Either you're pretty or you're not.
Not just looking online,
not just being some creepy old dude with a credit card going,
well,
I'm only just shuttle wiring.
I will buy your wrenches and one as it's lost him $2,000 a month.
Right?
I don't have time for a woman on my wife.
I'm 73 years old.
Oh.
Like my balls.
Like,
well,
I was in a,
when I was in,
uh,
Diego Garcia,
which is this rant,
this small island in the middle of nowhere and isn't it?
It's a military eyes.
An island named Diego Garcia and they don't know who that dude is.
That's ridiculous.
Did they just run out of names?
No,
it was that when they got there,
that's the name of the island.
Who named it.
They don't,
whoever was there before them,
it was some Portuguese explorer who just randomly found this island.
That's hilarious.
What a dickhead.
He named it after himself.
Well,
I guess isn't that the idea of America?
America was poochy.
Yeah.
I mean I don't allegedly,
I don't know anything about that,
but there's a Snopes thing on that.
I should probably look that up.
America Snopes ever cook can,
I think that's one of those things that's not true,
but everybody always says it like,
um,
uh,
like one of them is that they used to burn witches.
She's,
you know,
they didn't really used to burn witches.
They didn't burn witches that didn't burn witches.
Man.
What they do these hang them.
Jesus,
the burning of the,
which thing?
It's like this really common thing that's in our heads,
but they used to do apparently when the only time a named,
um,
the only time they did it on a regular basis was a religious times during Europe
during,
uh,
like I think like during the Martin Luther time,
I think they did a lot of burning.
They're burned.
People didn't believe or just were different.
Or if you didn't like somebody just called him a witch and then they had to
prove they're not a witch.
Yeah.
Uh,
he just completely random.
Yeah.
That's hilarious that you would have to prove that you're not a,
which they did.
They do stuff where it's like,
if you like,
there's no way to prove you whenever it's like Dave Duncan water,
and if you lived,
you are,
which if you died you weren't,
which,
so it's like you're damned if you do.
You're damned if you don't
America best preachy America.
God,
I need to get an American at this man.
I need sunlight.
Liquid.
You look at that.
Bam.
Pyre legged.
This loose some weight.
Oh,
name male is,
you said it first.
I mean human being the fuck you said it.
Fries,
feelings.
Um,
snopes.com slowest fuck slopes.
Dotcom slow is shitty ass website for all your shitty ass information.
You need it.
slopes.com.
Apparently this is another story.
Oh God,
this is too confusing.
I'm not going to read all this.
This is a t l d r too long didn't read.
I love that.
When I see that I'm posts too long.
Didn't read you here.
They found water on Mars.
What?
Eh?
Yeah.
Water discovered on Mars by the rover.
The rover curiosity.
Substantial discovery made after an analysis of soil samples from the planet
surfaces has
uncovered water.
Isn't that the whole thing about the behold a pale horse that they say we're
going to go and colonize Mars?
Well,
I think if people stay
alive for the next thousand years,
we will.
I think it's going to take a long fucking time and some crazy motherfucker is
going to have to go over there first.
There's going to be some people that will go over there and it's a god damn one
way trip,
man.
You never coming back.
You're going to go over there once and that's it.
That's where you live now.
Are you ready?
Go.
And if that doesn't work or you run out of air,
you're going to suffocate via satellite and we're going to get to watch it all
on our phones
and that will be on live leak.com oh quickly.
It'll be live streaming.
The guy will die on TV.
Just like the challenger accident.
I mean,
there's no way you're gonna be able to stop it.
No one's gonna.
It's not the odds of them being able to get all the way to Mars and not a couple
of people not make it.
That's crazy.
When they build a Las Vegas Hotel Casino,
they average in three people die.
Do they really?
Yeah.
They assume three people going to die along the way of building this hotel.
That's cause it was three people didn't know how to keep the fucking mouth shut.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm sure you did.
They take care of a couple of people.
I'm sure.
Like the building high rises,
someone slips,
falls called it a day.
Oh No.
I can't imagine how many people are going to lose on the way to Mars.
Well,
I think I really liked the idea of a sending,
you know,
the way they're doing it,
like with this curiosity,
they can learn a lot of shit.
They can,
they can do analytics on soil.
They can send back photographs and information.
They can do a lot of things without risking people's lives,
but as long as as human beings just going to be the one person wants to be the
first guy that lands on Mars,
he wants to be the Neil Armstrong with Mars.
There's always going to be one of those guys.
There's always somebody.
Yeah.
Who wants to be the explorer sometimes man,
you get lost in the whole,
I would have to say that.
I think if they're going to do that,
the first thing they would probably do is try that out on the moon.
Try some like terraforming,
go over there,
try to build some sort of structure.
They've even figured out how to make walls using the sand and the the,
the the the dirt of the moon and in a three d printer they figured out a way to
bond this.
Have you seen that Jamie?
This,
this photos of it?
Yeah.
Three d printer use to build base on the moon.
They've devised this a three d printer that they think they can transport
printer to boost.
Didn't they want to send like a married couple in this space for us.
And then they halfway there,
she wasn't,
she gives up,
she'll be deep sex with them anymore and he disappears.
And he goes on.
Melissa Gorg on him.
And uh,
he,
uh,
he winds up taking her just like that guy in the book.
God gave him some Shit at New Jersey.
He rapes her on TV.
Um,
yeah,
building a lunar base with three d printing.
This is a,
what they're planning on doing it.
There's a,
there's actually a,
an animated thing.
Uh,
we could see the,
the,
the Mo,
the rover move,
move the rover move.
But look at these photos.
This is plan C,
that photo,
the honeycomb.
This is,
um,
the three d printer,
is going to be able to make these walls that are essentially just some compound
that's created with the soil.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's a one that right there,
that photograph is a 1.5 ton building block that was produced as a demonstration
of the three d printing techniques using simulated lunar soil.
So they did it with something that would be like,
you know,
similar in consistency and the design is based on a hollow closed cell structure
reminiscent of bird bones to give a good combination of strength and weight.
So they would fly this printer up there and then just start building these walls
with this printer out of the lunar soil.
Man.
My printer always jams had suck if you were up there and your printer jams.
Ha Yeah.
Absence Sandy.
Some new shit.
Can you send me some,
some quick sum it up here.
Yeah.
I need to clean my heads or something.
I'm out of the blue ink.
Well the idea is that,
you know,
there'll be able to,
they know that they can fly shit up there that can do this so they could
actually send some sort of rover type robotic thing up there with these printers
and build these houses before we even get there.
Jesus,
they just flew,
I think it was an f 16.
They flew it as a,
um,
as a drone.
They successfully fluent and landed it and they achieve supersonic speeds all
done completely as a drone.
This is for the first tie end at air force base.
Wow.
Yeah.
They just did this.
This was a here,
I'll pull this up.
When did the robots take over?
Well,
it's getting close.
That's my point.
Uh,
what about combining?
What robots are we going to,
I'm going to miss all the cool shit.
I'm born too early or too late.
Know you're going to be fine.
F 16th drone.
Yeah,
and the F 16,
man,
there's a video of it to pull it up,
dude.
Uh,
F 16 drone fighter jet flies without pilot.
It's fucking incredible,
man.
My point is if they can do this,
they can also get some,
I mean,
they can get the rover to land on the moon.
They can also,
or on on Mars.
They can also get one to land on the moon.
They get something more complex now because the rover's a few year old,
a few years old now,
and you know,
who knows what they're going to have 10 years from now.
They're gonna have like,
look at this.
This is a fucking jet flying with no one in it.
They're doing it all completely remote.
Look at that.
That's the same as,
is that good or bad for us?
I'm not good.
Not Good.
I'm just that dude that's bad for humans.
It's bad for mankind.
Well these things are gonna start thinking.
I mean right now it's just stupid.
But one day they're going to make one that's really fucking smart and it's going
to be like the car's cartoon where they talk to each other.
I don't want to bomb Iraq
and bomb DC.
This ends bad for mankind.
I mean,
do these guys watch Scifi flicks?
How do you,
how do you call yourself a test pilot if you're on the ground?
Cause it says test pilot.
This is why I became an into this program is the,
to me are the epitome of my career.
This is what it was all about.
I mean,
to be able to take this area,
oh,
about slaving mankind,
our robot overlords.
That's what it's all about.
God.
Yeah.
You know when the opening sequence of the terminator movie,
the first one where the terminators are walking around,
you see them stepping on skulls and stuff and you see those giant flying robot.
That's drones,
man.
100% it's,
it's real.
It's all common.
I mean,
whether or not they're actually going to be against humanity,
my feeling is robots,
unless we programmed them to have survival instincts won't.
So they won't see us as a threat and you know,
I don't think they'll have any biological instincts at all at the the need to
survive.
They need to stay on or be on or off.
I don't think unless we program them with those ideas,
they're not going to have those ideas naturally.
I don't think those are natural ideas.
I think those ideas had been sort of like they've grown inside the human animal
from a long,
long life on this planet and various forms from single cell,
the multicell to Malmo to you know,
ape to whatever the fuck we are now.
It's a long ass process.
How long til chick start banging robots?
Then we got to compete with robots real quick.
There are any bang and robots.
They already have like the Sib,
Ian's and dildos and men just got the fleshlight really recently and the
flashlight is totally manual.
You've got to grab it stick anyway.
You got to do it all yourself.
Women have things that fuck them.
They have things that will fuck them.
They have vibrators now in cvs we make you buy vibrators and put it on and drive
home.
Yeah,
they have those back massagers things.
Big Ground Rubber Ball,
back massager thing.
It's robots beat in the been doing nothing,
chilling.
Now it's going to happen.
There's no way you're going to be able to stop that can come home.
Your girlfriend's getting shagged by a transformer.
You're fucked.
You have.
If robots were are created by women,
that's what we're going to be really fucked because they're going to make robots
that are exactly the way they want.
A man who just sensitive with big Dicks,
just weak bitches,
just weak pitches that listened to them.
Skinny jeans.
I mean if you get allow,
if you could allow like really angry feminists to program robots to be any a
male robot,
to be anything they want it to be.
How would those guys be?
Would they be really sensitive and just fun to be around and really nice or
would they just be smeeds meek little email comic hale alt comics
guys just stand there in front of a microphone and don't even move and uh,
mentally,
easily the push around all comics,
male feminists comics,
there's just a male feminist and she's,
I don't know why it's all,
it's everywhere.
It's just what you said earlier is that people don't want to,
they don't want to catch up.
They just want to stay,
stay lazy and they want everybody else to slow down too.
Yeah.
It's,
it's dumbing the masses.
It's not even dumb.
A lot of all people aren't dumb.
They're very smart,
very smart.
Just weak.
I think sometimes Clever's more important than funny sometimes.
Well,
it's,
they're trying to play to the back of the room a lot.
There's a lot of that,
you know,
I think you see that a lot.
Like,
oh,
I watch,
I'm like,
wow,
that's clever,
but I'm not necessarily going,
Hahaha.
Allowed.
Well,
we had,
um,
Matt full tron in here and he was talking about how that kind of like fucked him
up in his career because he used to write for the back of the room and he wasn't
writing for the crowd.
And then he realized once he started going on the road like,
oh,
I fucked up.
Like I'm writing for a bunch of people that are like cynical and they've heard
every joke in the book and they don't really want to see common anymore.
They want to see something,
some unexpected.
Yeah.
Animal attack.
When they want to see something unexpected,
they want to see something that's not really standup comedy.
They want it to be like ironic.
But when you,
you know,
when you pay money to go on the road and you're in buffalo and you got to do
standup at a comedy club,
that ironic shit ain't gonna fly.
Nope.
And so the,
you know,
he was saying that he found that and I was like,
oh,
I was writing jokes for comedians.
I wasn't even writing for humans.
Well,
it gets interesting when you do every level of comedy,
like open Mikes,
you're playing the comedian,
so you kind of got to learn.
That was a big thing for me because I get,
the first five years I did standup comedy,
I just played bars.
I mean just like roadhouse bars,
like instant Vegas.
Yeah,
just this crazy boss.
I couldn't,
at that time they weren't letting locals play the comedy clubs because they
could just fly out comics from a la.
So we had the maid or make our own scene and I would just find crazy bar gigs.
Like anywhere I could perform,
like we would go in between bands like you'd have band,
like hard metal bands playing,
bring out the comedians and I would have to go out and just deal with all the
hecklers,
shut them up,
and then bring the other comedians on.
We would take any kind of Gig like that.
Now when do you,
when you started,
what year was it like a,
I've been doing it for like 16 years,
so like 90969790690 seven what was the scene like in Vegas?
Like,
how did you start out dead?
How would you,
how would he start out if you're,
when I started,
there was one open mic every other week in the entire city.
There was nothing,
nobody who had been working at.
And I've been doing it and I'm just like,
I've got to get up.
So I just decided to create my own comedy gigs.
And what I would do is I would just,
every night I would find a dead bar.
I'm like,
your bars debt,
let me have the night and I'll get it going.
And I would create an open mic in which I would host and I would do,
you know,
get the crowd going,
deal with the hecklers,
bring up the comedians.
And then I had my own,
uh,
Improv troupe,
which we started and we gotten to all the station casinos.
So I had open mikes going one place,
my improv troupe performing another place.
And that's just how I,
uh,
perform forever.
That's very smart,
man.
That's very genius of you.
It's Kinda how I am right now.
It's like I have a stern certain style of comedy I like to do.
So I create my own environment and in which to do it at,
which is,
you know,
the naughty show or the,
uh,
comedy,
rap battles and stuff like that.
I just,
that's why I enjoy doing so I could create a brand that's very smart of you
though.
It shows a lot of get up and go.
There you go.
All right.
You know what?
Someone's going to do this.
Let me put this shit together.
I wish I could play a little more bald too.
I guess I,
I'm so focused on creating my own things.
I'd like to do just the normal stuff too,
but I really enjoy these shows.
Like it's what I enjoy doing.
That's why I'm very passionate about something wrong with that.
What I'm,
what I'm saying is it showed a lot of get up and go on your part to like start
these nights and put these things together and have comedy shows where there was
nothing else.
They're going on a lot.
Other people go,
ah,
I can't do it in the city.
You know,
you,
you either,
that was a very ingenious sort of a way we'll work around,
you know,
industrious of you said there's a way around us.
If no book me and there's no shows.
I got to make my own shows and I will just,
you know,
it's very blessed that growing up,
uh,
we didn't physically fight with each other.
We just racked each other.
We were like verbally fishes.
All my buddies in high school,
all of them were like victims of divorce.
Their pants they were doing,
they were kind of hurt children in weird way.
They like they,
they
had a weird off family.
They were,
they came from loving parents but the parents were divorced.
It affected them.
They were kind of like her children.
So we were vicious with each other.
I remember like moments where we'd go to a local pizzeria,
pawn tilos and whoever got sat in the wrong seat,
you are going to get pounded on all night by everybody and they wouldn't let you
up from the booth and it would just boom,
boom,
boom.
And you would just get vicious.
And I just learned to not take it personal and just hit back and it's like,
to this day that's really helped me with hecklers.
I just,
you know,
I don't really think I just react now.
So,
uh,
yeah.
I mean I had always had something like that.
It was just where I came from.
Do you find though that when you're dealing with an actual polite crowd that
wants to hear material,
they like,
hey,
I don't know,
is throwing anything at me again.
It is weird.
I have to learn to tell them how much I liked them too.
That was my transition.
I had a problem with that when I went from bars to do nicer comedy club.
I was a different transition.
I was ready.
I was like,
not ready,
but I was used to combat comedy.
You know,
like I had a,
I didn't do what you did.
I didn't,
I never created my own thing.
But I did a lot of bars.
We did a lot of bars,
but it was,
they were already created for me.
I got super lucky.
I came along in Boston in the 80s there was so much work in town that you never
had to leave.
You could be a full time professional comedian and work from one to two and a
half,
three hours drive at the most for gigs and you would work almost every week and
every day.
I mean,
you can do whatever you want it.
There's so much work during the weekdays for mostly free stuff.
You know,
where you,
where you would take,
you know,
take your time and get tight.
But then on the weekends,
and it's a lot of weekday gigs,
there's just,
you know,
drive to New Hampshire,
drive to a western Massachusetts,
drive to Maine,
drive to Attleboro drive to Marlborough,
drive to here and you got to use to these really fucking terrible places
standing on top of milk crates and nobody's paying attention and the hockey
games on.
I went to Montreal before I ever played a common,
a real I before I was,
I was a regular at any comedy club.
When you say mantra,
you mean the festival I got,
I had just came to la and I was just a ball of fire and I got picked up and they
brought me to mound trail.
I didn't even know what it was at the time.
The only time I'd ever play the club was about a year before I'd opened for Nick
Depalo at the,
uh,
at the,
the Riviera,
which was booked by the guy who eventually went on to be a on the soprano.
Steve.
Sure.
Rip Up Bobby.
Yeah,
the big guy.
So that was the first time I ever played calmed me cause I've never really
played great guy.
Shrimp is awesome.
You know what,
man,
once in a while I rub people the wrong way.
I don't know why.
Just people in authority,
I,
they,
I make them nervous,
but there's certain people that they were in that we're an tourist for being
prickly.
There were always really,
really nice to me.
Like Dan Mer in Tempe Improv.
You'd always hear these crazy stories about him,
but he was the nicest do to me.
I was so thankful for her and Steve Shrimp.
Oh was the same way like this guy was in the tourist thorny
dude.
Nice do,
but could that,
you know,
bust some balls.
Always really nice to me.
[inaudible] is just fair.
If you are a Douche,
he would just call you on it.
That was the what,
what what it was,
you're not a dickhead.
He's finally,
I never had a problem with shrimp,
but he's a great guy,
was just really nice to me,
gave me spots,
made me feel like I had a chance in something.
I was the first comic to ever get booked twice at his club out of Vegas at the
time and it was just such an amazing feeling and working with the Apollo was
just like who I'd always looked up to.
It was real funny.
It was great because I was performing with him and he was having a fight with
his girlfriend at the time.
I mean a full on brawls like before he got on stage they'd be screaming each
other,
go up and perform,
get off stage,
tell me what a great job I did and then go back to arguing with his girlfriend.
I got to get him on.
He's,
he's got something coming up.
We actually have been going back and forth with email whenever he's a in La
again.
We'll definitely have one of the funniest dudes,
man heads.
Some of the funniest jokes I've ever heard.
What the fuck happened with him and already Lang do you,
do you know what happened there?
No,
I was just told that you know,
he won't talk more sports and already wanted to just shoot the shit.
You know I,
that's all I heard.
That doesn't seem right.
It seems like already loves talking sports too and you know,
they can't like,
I dunno what else.
I have a really great sports podcast too called punching in sports.
You don't like my sports podcast?
You can't say I have a really great anything I do let you say hi.
I have a really great show.
I do love it.
I love that.
I believe the Ari and to Jason Tebow and that's kind of like people like it,
it's a sports podcast but they like when we talk about anything but sports,
it's like really weird.
You know,
people like talking about anything,
man,
they like people that talk about shit.
That's interesting.
And sometimes if you just had a sports podcast,
talked only about sports,
it wouldn't be as exciting as a sports podcasts that mostly talked about sports.
But if some other shit came up and it was interesting and you go,
oh,
we can't talk about that.
That's the beautiful thing about having a podcast.
Nobody can tell you that you can do whatever the fuck you want whenever you want
to do it.
Yeah,
I love it.
I love the uncensored is of a podcast.
I love podcasting.
I love podcasting almost.
As much as I love doing standup and I love doing standup.
I love talking.
I'm with you 100% I agree with you saying my opinion,
I have opinions,
you know,
and some people get really mad at me.
They get so angry that they don't,
I don't share their opinion,
but it's just like I'm just talking.
That's always going to be the case,
man.
It's always going to be a bunch of people that get pretty pissed off.
They do.
They get angry with me,
real rigid and the right people were rigid and their ideas.
Sam Tripoli,
I just in the middle of nowhere,
it's like,
and the things they you with you,
the things they say to me,
climate change is not real.
Right?
It's just the things they say to fucking moron.
There's so fishes.
I think a lot of times they just want you to respond.
That's exactly what they want.
I would never,
you know,
back when I was growing up and I met somebody famous,
I would never be vicious to him like that.
Can you even imagine though,
what it's like growing up in this age where anybody you like,
you just reach
out and tell them their icon?
Well,
it makes nobody famous.
There's nothing to spa.
You know,
certain that's not true.
It certainly makes people that other people talk about a lot.
You know,
if your puff Daddy,
you're famous,
no matter what area you live in,
the difference is you're no longer beyond reproach.
Somebody can get ahold of you and go,
you're fucking album sock to big fat.
Fuck good pile is shit.
Fuck you.
You Queer,
you can say whatever you want.
I said that about Emma.
I didn't say sorry.
I go,
I watched him on that like a college football halftime show and I go,
well it looks like,
yeah.
M&Ms Back on drugs so the new album should rock.
I just tweeted that and dude,
every fake mnm Twitter account just started blasting me like five or six of them
just start calling me out.
And it was just some random,
I didn't even Hashtag m and M and I just,
and it wasn't even mnm that said that it was just random.
People take fake m and m's,
M and m fans.
Well and you put out a little hate and he got a little,
again,
I don't think that was,
hey,
I said it was going to be a great album.
They don't want to think that it's the alcohol or the drugs that fuel the
creativity.
Sam Aaa and I don't think it does either from the gene.
I think it's genius.
You just hadn't be fucked up when you came up with the idea,
have you seen,
well you've seen the video of folks who haven't seen the video.
Jamie pull up that just the video of m and m tripping so people could say like
Sam Tripoli wasn't talking out of school.
I mean he like went way out of his way to look really fucked up.
I mean he was working at,
what are you talking about?
The video of m and m were the one that you commented on it.
He was like,
yeah,
that's,
that's like the Molly is hitting while he leaned forward and everything.
Looking at him like,
come on.
His mouth is wide open.
He's leaning forward like severely leaning forward is rolling his eyes side
aside.
That's true.
I've been there.
I've been on shrooms.
I've had that moment where I'm like,
is this real life?
Is this his video they're playing?
They probably played it.
He was joking around,
obviously joking around a lot.
Maybe I don't even care.
I'm not judging is just barely paying attention.
Some old dude with a fucking suit on Berger who's great.
He's just like one of those old guys.
He just doesn't give a shit.
When I was old football guys.
Yeah,
now he's done.
He's done now.
Now he's back to normal.
Yeah man,
you put some hate out there,
Sam trip.
But he got it back.
It's,
hey,
I ain't judging am I to judge.
I've told my party and my day.
Well,
the point is that there's a lot of hate out there online.
Well there's a lot emotional reaction.
People want you to think their way.
They want you to like what they like,
they don't digest.
They just see word and they just react to it.
See Adam Levine and lady Gaga got it until a little Twitter beef and lady Gaga
owned him.
Really with one line cause a Adam Levine was like criticizing some of her work.
Like,
you know,
hey,
I'm proud.
He was like,
I'm proud to do pop music but this is blah blah blah blah blah.
And so you know something about art.
And so she comes back on and she goes,
oh look,
we got here guys.
It's the art police.
Yeah.
Well.
Oh guys,
the art police is here.
Come on,
look at his quote.
I unabashedly love writing and performing pop music for both myself and in
capital level letters.
Everyone around me.
That's it.
It doesn't need any extra sauce.
Shut your hole.
Pretty man.
Shut your dumb hole.
That's really funny,
man.
That's really funny.
She's the one beast with a couple people.
Yeah.
Hilton and Madonna that the three of them would go and look at his,
his quote.
Scroll it up.
What did he say?
Me thinks those dosed protests too much.
Yikes.
Shot Thou dost protest too much.
Shut up dude.
By the way,
I'm not an artist.
I sang in a band and I make music with my friends.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's a self inflicted wound right there.
Well,
not only that,
what he just said,
I'm not an artist.
If you're not an artist,
you need to shut the fuck up.
If you're saying and you're not an artist,
what are you doing?
And I don't feel like she protested too much.
How about,
how has that though?
How was he not an artist?
Like what are we pretending?
Pretending this singing is not an art and I'm like,
why you pretend a being self deprecating there?
I just feel like he shit on himself.
You've just basically say you're,
what you're doing is not artistic.
It's foolish.
Self deprecating tip deprecating behaviors.
What it is,
deprecation man.
Now he put out that one album where he just had his,
he just broke up with his girlfriend obviously.
She ripped his heart out and it was a pretty good album,
but the whole album was about her,
her bay basically breaking her heart man.
Breaking his heart.
Yeah.
The other way around.
Whenever he's a Dick,
this,
that,
that's silly.
Why do you give a fuck with Lady Gaga sings?
You know why white guys,
you know,
I know it shouldn't say he's a Dick.
Maybe he's a nice guy who was drunk maybe fucked up.
Maybe he's in a bad frame of mind.
I don't know.
The guy just,
you know,
it goes back to your joke about all the sensitive white band guys.
There's a lot of that out there,
which a lot of those guys get into that position too.
There's also the thing that happens when people get into that sort of position
of prominence where they feel like they have to stand up,
you know,
for what's their idea of what's right.
You know,
so him shitting all over her music like,
c'mon,
I unabashedly performed pop music for myself and in capital letters.
Everyone around me like,
come on,
just that sentence shows me you're not that bright.
That's a not very bright sentence.
It's on a zoom call out other comics on like material and stuff like that.
Oh,
you can't do that.
Those kind of jokes.
And what do you give a fuck?
I've never called out anybody for anything other than stealing I,
that's why I agree wholeheartedly brother.
That's the only people that got problems with.
We both have friends at suck.
We know them.
We know those.
There's a few that hang around the store.
They've always been terrible.
They're always going to be terrible.
I hug him every time I see him.
I don't care.
You know,
as long as you're nice,
as long as you're nice offstage,
I don't care how you are.
I mean,
as long as you don't get crazy and want to ask me advice or you know,
try to get me to rewrite your jokes,
get alone.
There are some bad conversations that I've been out of.
Hey,
how do you think I should fix that?
Bit like,
oh,
come on man.
This is not even possible.
I can't help you here.
But yeah,
it's hard to tag somebody else's stuff.
Not just hard to tag.
How do he make something funny that's not funny at all and someone comes up to
you?
I'm having a hard time with this.
This bit where I eat babies,
I can't fucking clean it up just at the problem with me is I've watched so much
comedy in my life.
I can see when the tricks are coming.
There's tricks,
comics do some tricks and not judging them.
It's just the way it is.
It's Jedi mind tricks.
It's whatever I can,
I've watched it for so long.
I,
if I know your act before you walk on stage,
I just can't watch comedy.
It's very hard for me to watch comedy right now unless it's someone I've heard a
lot about or I don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
I gotta be honest with you.
You're,
you're saying that and I experienced just the opposite.
I just can't watch.
I think you're very hard on a bunch of shitty comedian.
Maybe that's it.
Maybe I need to find a,
a funnier group of people,
but that's,
no,
really,
you're,
you're at the,
you're doing some shows,
like some of those late night spots at the store or whatever.
Open mic nights and certain places you can get around a bunch of tricks.
You're not supposed to watch those.
You know when those guys are there,
you get out of the room.
I just can't watch comedy.
That's not true.
Joey Diaz is going on stage.
You're going to watch.
I can watch him.
But those are the,
like the,
the legends,
you know.
But it's very hard for me.
And I'm not saying I'm anything better than anybody.
I just,
I'm just a dude doing standup,
but it's just,
I can't watch it.
I'm gonna just don't watch the bad stuff too.
It's not that difficult.
I wish they'd tell me when they're bad so I don't walk in and see it.
Well,
you're going to get that.
People are trying shit out there trying to get good.
You're going to get bad.
Yeah.
Well on it though and I don't dwell on it.
Don't be all like fucking Adam,
whatever his name is.
Lou,
get all lady Gaga with people and what's his name?
Levine.
Pretty pretty bastard.
It's about this thing for the ladies.
It's tough to go through life being that handsome and not just get a delusional
sense of your own intelligence.
People like you so much.
Beautiful cheekbones.
She's girls just skin perfect amount of stubble.
You Lot just can cross it off your list.
All your sexual must do is you've got God,
it must be nice or not.
It's not natural.
You know,
you might maybe better off being a chimp.
Better off just doing an old school primates style that that trickery of like
being on a screen,
sing a certain song,
having them all going crazy and throwing panties at you.
It shits on natural when it comes down to he's got weak genes.
Look at this shit he's writing.
It's a little pea brain because that is how he feels or he knows that's what
will sell.
That statement that he said is it dumb statement?
The whole thing about it.
I unabashedly make pop music.
That's just something a dummy says like I'm not saying he's dumb mean he might
not be dumb.
Maybe it's just tough to get your,
your your expression out 140 characters.
Yeah,
but what do you see in it is it is,
you know,
it's way easier to do this.
I mean,
think about some of the shit that I've said so far that I had to clarify and
just the explaining myself about him.
So you're great with footnotes.
You explained to them you have footnotes.
Leave Lady Gaga.
First of all,
this is what you should pay attention to with lady Gaga,
her tremendous Hass.
That should be it.
She loves showing all you're paying attention to pull those pictures up of lady
Gaga is was asked from the grammys and listen to me,
Mr. Levine,
if you're concentrating on her saying you're doing it wrong,
okay,
what you should be concentrating on is the fact that her and Miley Cyrus had an
old school south park sloughed off on the video music awards and Lady Gaga
dominated her.
She dominated her without any of the tongue sticking out without any stupid shit
with the foam finger just with this tremendous body she has suspicious yet.
Pull that shut up.
Look at this dude.
Come on with your bad self.
Look at her ass.
Give us a full photo.
What do you see the,
there's some great pictures.
We see the whole body.
Her whole,
her body's in tremendous shape.
Man,
that is a great app.
My God,
dude,
her body's in some breathe through it.
She wins.
Her body wins.
That's when a breathe.
Why are you talking about her singing?
If you don't like it,
don't like it,
but what?
You know,
why would you complain about that?
I guess it was like some music video she did that showed various art styles or
something.
I Dunno what the fuck it was all about.
Who Cares?
Look at her ass and that's the con,
the comparison.
Mature.
That is hilarious.
It's rude.
When I was hired,
I was talking about on stage,
she got fuck you money and she just,
that's a fucking thing.
That's all that was.
That whole thing was,
she probably just threw it together.
She's young,
you know,
you shouldn't be that famous when you're that young.
You're 20 years old.
He's trying to find yourself and you're doing it on television like that and
someone allows you to put that together and do that on television.
Or maybe she likes it.
Who knows?
Maybe when you're 20 that's cool.
I love,
fuck you mom.
I love her big dumb teeth.
You remember when there's things that you liked when you were young?
You know,
there was certain comic books she's like,
look forward to,
and if you had to read them today,
he'd be like,
what is this piece of shit?
The fact that he loved him.
Maybe that's what it's like for her.
She's 20 years old,
right?
Which she thinks is awesome.
It might be that 100% she might like watch that every night and go,
I fucking knocked it out of the park.
I was watching Ghostbusters the other day.
It's still a great movie.
But I remember when I was a kid watching it,
how my mind was blown at how funny that movie was.
Well that's a different time though.
There's a thing about comedy that comedy has a very short sort of lifetime to it
and then if you go back and try to watch some comedies from a long time ago,
a lot of them don't hold up at all.
You could see like even blazing saddles.
It's a great fucking movie.
You go back and watch it today and compare it to something like,
did you see the world's end?
Yes.
Fucking whole Larry an awesome movie.
It was a great movie.
Here's my thing about the worlds.
Then I
think that put the end,
the whole rape joke controversy because they do a five minute bit in there about
rape joke and nobody say anything.
So I'm like,
okay,
that's cool.
It was hilarious.
It was five minutes.
I'm whether where,
where?
Oh,
is that the one with the bar or is that the one where,
uh,
with Seth Rogen,
Oh,
I thought you were talking about the one would send the row against Jesus
Christ.
What did you see?
That one?
What was the,
this is the enzyme that was hilariously different movies and I let go.
I love that one.
I saw the world very funny.
The world's ended the robots in the pub.
I haven't seen it.
I'll go wash.
Look,
I'll come back with a book report on em.
Well,
those guys are funny,
dumb and dumber.
That doing a reunion.
Yeah.
That's not necessary.
That's a mistake at the Emmy's.
He beat out a breaking bad.
Who did?
Uh,
Jeff Daniels,
his character on newsroom newsroom.
Oh,
that's right.
He,
that's the same guy.
It's hard to remember that.
That's the same guy.
When you see in there with this silly look at his face.
I don't want to watch this.
Who knows though.
It was it the fairly brothers still probably,
yeah.
We have to look up.
Don't probably means it's a fucking computer in front of you.
Google at Sun.
Pretty sure it is.
Probably in 2015 yes it is.
Well,
if it's a fairly brothers,
that makes sense because they know what the fuck they're doing.
That's their movie.
Maybe they can do it again.
They're supposed to put out the movie,
but then that magician movie didn't do that well,
so they pulled funding on it even though the magician movie was hilarious.
I heard that Burt Wonderstone.
It's hilarious.
Hilarious too.
It's really fucking funny.
I watched it on the flight,
the international flight where they give you like 90 movies to watch and I was
one of it and I'm like,
this is really funny.
Why didn't it go?
What happened?
I did a dude,
who knows?
I don't know how they market it.
I don't know man.
What's his face?
Steve Carell's a great,
great comedic actor.
I don't know how well some of his movies do,
but he's a great actor.
Yeah.
That movie,
for whatever reason,
just didn't seem appealing when it was out and the movie theaters to me there,
I thought it was the way it was marketed or something.
Maybe.
I don't know man,
but it was,
and let me tell you,
Jim Carrey murders in that.
He's so good in that movie.
Is he the magician?
He's like the bad guy.
Magician in it.
Oh,
all right.
I need to go see that.
It was great,
man.
It was a great movie.
I watched it on a plane,
but I didn't watch all of it,
but I was howling.
It was quick solve it though,
and he was great.
Hi Jim Carrey was great in a in a kickass too.
I love kick ass.
Kick ass one was one of the best movies I've ever watched in terms of comedy
cast too.
It's good.
It's it.
Number one is a little better,
but that's hard to beat it because it's such a great movie.
Yeah,
but that little girl in that movie is so smart.
There's some of these,
these child actors,
she like,
man,
how do they graph that kind of motion?
Cause they're brilliant.
They're like,
they all go on like Harvard and Yale to school and stuff like that.
Cause they're way smarter than the average kid at that age.
I don't think it's hard to act,
man.
I think there's a lot of kids out there that can do.
I honestly do.
Yeah.
But I think there's some kids you see that they're just playing a kid and then
you see there's some who like have the moment.
That girl who's also in let me in.
She's incredible.
Yeah,
she's really good.
But I don't think that it's that hard to do.
I okay,
I'll give you that.
I did a movie this year and it was like,
I'm like,
Oh shit.
Done this before.
But it's like,
yeah,
but this,
some of these kids are just able to just nail this very adult motion.
Yeah,
no,
they definitely are.
Especially if it's really well written and they're really smart.
I met a Dakota fanning's at her name.
Really young girl ones.
Very,
very smart kid.
Very smart cheese.
A another one.
There was a brilliant young actress,
but I always get weirded out by the idea because I like Miley Cyrus.
I think everybody should be able to do whatever the fuck they want to do.
However,
are you sure that's what you want?
And then you show you're ready to handle the repercussions of that because being
a Miley Cyrus has gotta be mindbogglingly difficult to not go crazy.
If you look at all of them,
everyone who ever was a young superstar,
how many of them made it through Ron Howard,
Jodie Foster,
and who knows?
Who knows how crazy they really are?
They seem awesome.
I mean,
Ron Howard seems totally together,
so it was Jodie Foster,
but think about how many of them went loco.
Almost all the rest.
Really.
I know a couple.
I know him personally.
I know a couple of them that were famous when they're young and they're fucking
crazy man.
It all wired wrong.
Just like moving around and working,
but you're like,
oh,
this is where that is,
and that's where this is and how'd you get wired?
But that all you've been famous since you were five,
so that never even grew.
Oh Wow.
That's that Justin Bieber situation,
you know?
It's like,
just seems like he's got everything and I mean his dad's his manager,
but what can his dad tell him?
I don't think when you could have outside influences,
that's when things start going real really crazy.
Yeah.
There's no doubt about that.
There's no doubt that if you are a regular human being like we all are and you
don't slowly get inoculated to the idea of fame,
you don't develop some character,
you don't get older,
you don't get wiser.
You just jump into it from the time you're a baby.
Your reality is going to be so much different than everyone else's.
It's going to be wild animal.
That's what you are.
You become like a wild animal.
You're not taught the proper way to act.
You're not trained in the proper way of being in society,
so you're just reacting however you want to react.
Well,
I don't know about that,
but you don't develop character and a normal person does.
Being accepted or rejected,
learning how to coach people,
how you treat people or you're going to be famous from the jump.
And that just that alone,
having that royalty thing being so much more.
Look at Michael Jackson and look at,
you know,
how many of them had to become that way?
Donny Osmond,
I'd be the most normal.
Yeah,
but cause he's still at his family.
I mean Mormonism.
Yeah,
keep it together.
Had a bunch of people.
But then it's like just had some crazy
kids come out.
But even think about Michael Jackson.
I mean that fame is beyond anything anyone will ever get to.
I mean,
he was the big thing plan.
He couldn't leave his house.
So every day's like probably looking at himself in the mirror and just imagine
if you looked at yourself in the mirror all day,
every day.
It just like you'd start nitpicking herself.
Yeah.
You would start fucking with yourself.
Especially if you started changing things about your face.
Oh yeah.
No,
bleaching your skin.
Just wanting to get your lips thinner.
Yeah,
he did a lot of weird shit,
man.
I don't,
I wonder what he really did.
I wonder if ever we'll find out what were the full extent of the surgeries.
But he's the first guy in the history of television,
film.
Everything that we watched become like a freak like went from,
and I don't mean freaking a good way,
went from being this young boy who's this brilliant talent to being this man who
like hides and wants to be with children and has an amusement park and he's
Pale.
He's a white guy for no reason is knows as skinny.
His lips are skinny.
I mean his face changed so radically.
It might be the first guy that we've ever seen that has,
has done that.
The first person that we've ever seen that's grown from childhood to adult and
become like this kind of crazy freak like that.
And everywhere you go there's cameras.
You can't go anywhere,
you can't do anything.
It would just,
I mean that's just too much fame at the comparisons of his face when he first
started and then what he became over the years and what,
what do you,
what he looked like before he died.
It's really,
really shocking.
First of all,
who the fuck are these plastic surgeons?
How come nobody knows who these people are?
Like we know who the guy is who gave him the drugs that made him die,
but nobody knows who did all that work on him.
Like that guy did a terrible disservice.
Yes.
Like what did you do?
Like that guy,
that dude needed a hug and defend his lips out.
Well,
no,
you gave him so many no's operations.
It is,
knows caved in.
Like what can I doctor says yes to that one.
Who wants money?
I'm sure they just wanted the throat.
Immense amount of cash at.
Um,
do you have any photos?
See if you pull any photos of like the before and after.
That's okay.
It's just,
um,
it's madness.
What he's done to his body,
what he did to his face,
his eyes look at the size of his eyes when it was all over.
So strange.
It's so strange.
Yeah.
I made himself look white.
Well he,
he just did a lot of crazy shit to his nose.
His nose was so bad that they had to like graph skin over it.
It caved in.
It lost its support.
Started getting necrosis on his nose apparently too.
Isn't that what the one girl from the hill she did Heidi montage.
She did so much plastic surgery or nose was falling off.
I don't know.
Is that,
that's bullshit dude.
That's not real.
Uh,
I don't know.
Is that true?
That's sad shit man.
It's sad shit.
When you Pete see people start shoot and things.
You're shaving their face is hot and their nose down.
That lady,
that one one,
we got so much plus surgery.
She looks like a cat and that's what starts happening.
Yeah.
I think she started fixing that.
Let's see.
Let me see.
I think there was like something about cat lady fixing our face.
Cat Lady.
Fix your fuck and face.
But there's a lot of ladies that I see like in Beverly Hills that looked like
monsters.
Okay.
Yeah.
The Duck Lips.
It just like,
it's a hoot.
Who's,
who said that?
Sexy Duck Lips.
Okay.
Yeah.
She's trying to fix it.
She's making him while she was so pretty and the beginning,
man,
that's really sad.
I just,
when you have that much money and you just get bored,
okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll get the actually so pretty.
Yeah.
And then you just start injecting this and shaving that and why I also think
that the human mind is there's,
it's very possible for people to go crazy given the wrong circumstances,
giving the wrong,
you know,
wrong motivations.
The wrong people in their life.
People can blow fuses,
they can blast screws out and Dick can go nutty and they might not even realize
what they're doing while they're doing it.
Like,
did you see that lady that the uh,
the lady that um,
wow.
Is that really what she looked like?
She loves hot.
No.
Is that real?
Wow.
That's so crazy.
There's a before and after of the Cat lady where she was so funny.
No matter how much place surgery you get,
you can never remove the experience of life from your eyes.
You can always tell him the eyes,
how much stuff you've seen,
how much stuff you've been through.
It's always in the eyes.
He can't shave that off.
You can never get rid of the crazy either.
Right.
The,
you can't unsee what you've seen when the crazies in the eyes.
You see that shit
crazy.
Fucking people are everywhere too.
There's a woman in Korea that got addicted to plastic surgery,
so she didn't started injecting cooking oil into,
oh my God.
Did you see that?
No,
I don't want to say that.
You don't want to see it.
It's,
it's sad though and she was a really pretty young girl and she just,
apparently it's just like Anorexia,
just like bodybuilders that don't know how big they are.
There's we're susceptible.
We're susceptible to all sorts of weird variations in human behavior.
Yeah.
Addictions and were susceptible to going down these weird delusional path where
we don't see ourselves for what we look like.
Yeah.
We really calm with that.
With my fatness.
You,
what do you see how you see yourself?
I see myself as a sexy base.
Are you just a rock?
You like bulky at all?
I don't know what it is about my home mirror,
but it lets,
it makes me feel a lot better than this shot does.
Well,
look how you're sitting though.
It's bad.
Last year,
what do you want me to go?
Prop.
What do you want me to go but up.
That's it.
That's not bad right there.
Look,
how are you sitting?
Look predetermined.
I liked everywhere,
but here this is just it and I got to start working that I do.
You don't work out at all?
I do.
I just run.
But I got to do more.
Get to lift weights.
I got to get over the pink and blue weights.
I got to get to the Manuela and rob.
Black metal.
The raw.
Yeah,
the metal.
The blacks.
I to get over that it,
those pink weights aren't help.
How old are you now,
Sam?
Uh,
I'm 40 you got to do it before it's too late.
While your body is still pumping good fluid.
It's slowing down.
You got to get some sludge in your vein,
son.
I got to keep moving.
You can't because it's harder to do it when you're 40 than it is when you 39 and
harder when you 41 then is when you're 14 I know,
dude.
I know baby.
Can you pick a voice inside my head?
I am.
I'm trying to be please.
I need it.
You don't want me in there.
I'll make a recording for you.
I'll drive you crazy.
You throw that shit out of your head with a first day.
No,
my left foot was just skip and play over and over again.
Do you think that that would be like a good products of so me telling people
what to do like listen,
you can fucking do this like fear factor style.
I completely green and sell the fuck out of my fucking ass.
I'll personalize it to your name.
Sam Aaa.
Today's the day you are the hero in the movie of your own life.
It's time to get shit.
Pompez somewhat motivational speakers that do they just sell you tapes and just
tell me your name though.
I believe in yourself.
The way to do it right as it use the guy's name to make a,
a,
a real personal one and use her name if you really needed it.
Most people don't need it.
Most people are like,
bitch,
I don't need to hear you telling me what to do.
I'm with you man.
I think a lot of people would love it.
A lot of people need it.
You don't know how.
You obviously know how far this show reaches.
People live,
breathe and die.
This shit.
I did morning news in San Diego,
the wounds,
I wasn't even on the show.
She's like,
I heard your name on the Joe Rogan show,
hot chick out of San Diego.
You think you have a shot with her?
I could have if I want to keep pushing it,
but they
pay me.
Pay me doing radio from six in the morning until three in the afternoon.
Oh my God.
I was on tour,
uh,
comedy,
mad house down in,
uh,
why would they put you on so much?
Because they just wanted me to push product.
Jesus Christ son,
just let me know and I'll tweet it for you.
That's ridiculous.
Tell him don't do that.
Yeah,
well you know,
I like doing it.
I like going in there and see if I could rock it,
but man,
that was longer than it's ever been.
It's good to rocket,
but you also need to get some sleep before the show effected my show.
Oh,
it does my first shot.
It's just like my,
my energy is just really whacked right now.
Well especially because most comedians,
and it's not an excuse,
but the reality is we have a certain sleep cycle.
We go to bed at like two three four you know,
even later in the morning,
like people have said to me like,
Oh,
you're up pretty late.
Last night I saw your tweet and around two of the Ama like,
bitch,
I just started writing it too.
Right.
I went to bed at eight which I'll usually go to bed.
What time?
I go to bed in the morning.
Really?
Yeah,
like,
like what?
Like six my kids go to bed really early.
They go to bed at like seven ish,
seven 30 I read them stories by seven 30 there conked out.
Like they've got to get up in the morning and go to school.
I can't write until the house is quiet.
You can't trust me.
You cannot write Dick Jokes while he got little girls screaming.
Understand playing team Umizoomi and run around your house.
Like they,
they,
you know,
and you also have to pay attention to them while they're awake,
while they're home.
That's when we have fun together and when it's all done and everyone's asleep,
then I can get into my shed.
He goes to work,
daddy goes to work and sometimes it lasts a long time.
Like if I catch a wave,
like if I'm in the on roll,
like especially if I'm writing a blog or like lately I've been,
I've been writing a novel,
actually it started writing enough a few weeks ago.
I've been obsessed with this.
But you put out so much content.
I got a lot of shit.
My head man trying to get over my childhood.
And that child childhood made you who you are.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You know,
everybody has to have a shitty childhood.
Makes you awesome.
Hey man,
if it was handed to you,
you'd be lazy.
Yeah,
there's a little of that too.
But also,
um,
I enjoy the creative process.
I really enjoy it.
The only thing that keeps me for doing it,
it's distractions.
Whether it's playing pool or doing Jujitsu or other things in my life,
if,
or watching TV or something like that.
Those are the only distractions that actually keep me from creating things.
I'm at my happiest,
not at my happiest,
but I think a good source of happiness I should say,
I want to quantify it is when something comes out.
When I sit down and write something and it comes out,
I love it.
That's why I never understood joke stealing it because I love so much coming up
with an idea,
fine tuning it and presenting it to people and the reaction to it,
I enjoy,
you know,
it's like I could do just Crowdwork.
I could just rack the crowd for an hour,
just go every,
do an interview final who they are 'em and they'd be happy,
but that doesn't get me off.
What gets me off as coming up with an idea in my head,
fine tuning it,
tagging it,
and then presenting it to a crowd and getting a reaction from 300 strangers or
who I'm at.
How many people are in the crawl.
That is what an artist is.
That's why the guy saying he's not an artist.
It's so fucking silly.
You put together a song,
you're an artist,
shut your hole.
All right,
stop it.
And when you're an artist,
you get that satisfaction of someone appreciating your art.
That's what it is to make something good.
They appreciate your art and that's what these people are doing.
They're appreciating your art.
You,
you,
you put something together and the reward is when it comes out,
right?
You get a big laugh in the crowd.
Ah,
it's awesome.
I love it when I hear,
you know,
I'll go on the road and I'll meet some people are fans of the podcast and
they're in the middle of nowhere and they're doing their own podcasts.
And I love that they're like,
they're finding their own creative ways to put their things out that isn't
necessarily like,
Hey I got to get this podcast out cause I need to have this result,
which would lead to this.
And they just love the creativity.
I always think that's so cool man.
Just to be doing your own thing like allowed to death squad.
People in Ohio,
they have this whole desk squad network and a bunch of them do podcasts and I
think it's really cool,
man.
The Internet is filled with people that have their own podcast.
I get requests listened to them every day.
Someone says,
Hey,
check out my podcast.
Look if you do something it's good.
People will listen and then they'll tell people and so on and so on and it'll
grow.
And it's really that easy.
I mean I know I had a head start because I was already on television.
I did a bunch of other things before I started doing my podcast,
but it all just grew.
The first couple episodes is like a hundred people listened to it,
you know,
and nobody gives a shit.
It took,
it takes awhile.
I remember you talking about doing your podcast.
I think you'd just done Adam Carolla show,
right?
And you're like,
hey man,
I might try to do that.
Well,
we actually did it long before then,
but we never stuck with it.
We did it on Justin TV.
Yeah,
we used to do it,
uh,
after shows.
We used to do with this before anybody was doing podcasts.
We were doing these live streaming things from the green room.
We're going to answer questions.
They look a little chat room.
We would just talk shit for the Green Room.
It was fun.
And then one day,
um,
there was two people that inspired me,
Adam Carolla and also opie and Anthony.
Anthony [inaudible] has a place set up at his house and he has a green screen
and a tricorder and the whole thing.
I mean,
he tri caster and he has this incredible setup.
We can pretend he's in Manhattan with the city behind him.
He can make it like Africa.
He could make it like space that you can do whatever he wants and it's pretty
fucking dope.
And I saw that.
I was like,
damn,
it would be fun to do.
And so we started doing them on Ustream just,
you know,
three,
almost four years ago before years ago,
I think.
I think it's four years,
something like that.
Four years ago in December.
It's a long ass time.
Have you ever thought about putting in a green screen?
Yeah.
Too much work.
And now who gives a fuck?
You know,
it's distracting to have a bunch of shit going on,
but this place is gorgeous.
It's one more thing to think about too.
I don't want to think about shit.
It's gorgeous.
Gorgeous.
Like a girl.
I'm fucking,
you want to fuck my house?
Yeah,
I'll fuck you in your studio.
well we know what it is.
It's like,
it's what you can do if you can just design it from the ground up by herself.
I don't want a brick wall.
A brick wall.
I don't want to say what made that a old oak boom.
That's not the natural wall there.
You just know it in the wall that built,
you had someone build a wall.
Yeah.
Build a brick wall.
You know all around through the whole building.
You use just like being in front of brick walls,
like comedy clubs.
It feels organic though.
That's why I wanted this wooden table to the wooden table.
Feels like you feel it.
You know?
This is like this got a life to it.
This is reclaimed farm wood from a hundred year old farm.
Really?
Yeah.
They cut it down.
Supposedly they might have lied to me.
You might have found this shit.
It's made in the u s but it's really China until the stupid fuck.
It's organic.
Tell him it's gluten free.
What is this screen behind us?
This thing that's some shit that the fucking people who produced the TV show,
Scifi show created.
They put it back there.
They thought it was important to have something back there.
She makes the light look,
doesn't do anything now or is it just hangs out.
Just chills and turn the lights on.
Oh look at that
swimming pool at night,
but we don't think of that.
It'll do that to the wall to without that thing.
It'll just,
those are just a little lights that we have on the ground.
Well,
it looks great.
It sets a great tone in here.
Thank you very much,
Sam Trim.
Very sexy.
I'm glad you enjoy the Humvee halls.
Very excited about working with you to this weekend.
I,
uh,
I'm very excited about doing the cow.
As you can tell.
I'm excited about,
uh,
the comedy Magic Club.
I,
I'm,
I'm going over my set,
you know,
I,
I want to rock it,
but I also,
I,
you know,
I'm not a guy who likes to go into a comedy club and be like,
fuck you.
I'm gonna do what I want to do.
I love the county magic club.
I know they like it a little cleaner,
so I'm working on what my set should be.
Well,
I'm not going to be clean because I'm,
but I'm not going to.
I listen,
man.
I don't want it,
you know,
I don't know.
I actually don't know.
I'm just rambling.
I'm just trying to figure it out.
Like what I should do should finish that Starbucks coffee.
That's what it is.
Is that coffee or tea in there?
That's coffee.
You got fired up.
Well I've got to figure it out.
What I'm going to do.
It's a weird thing cause cause I'm working for you and you're like kind of do
whatever you want.
But then it's a club that's kind of what likes clean.
So what you're saying is you working for me,
but you're also working to impress the clubs.
He can come back.
Yeah.
No I do.
I get that.
I'm not there kind of comic.
So I get that and it's a great club.
They have their once a year maybe,
but it's like I don't want to go in there and be like,
just shit on the rules.
It's not my way.
It's not rules,
dude.
Don't worry about that.
Mike's fine.
He's a good guy.
He's not going to book anyway.
I get that.
But I don't know.
I have this thing that I'm like,
I don't want to piss people off.
I don't know why to shut a guy throwing a chair at me to worry about it.
That's the store.
I'm telling you this,
first of all,
the stores haunted,
you know that.
And I know that if I ever believed in ghosts and I never saw a ghost,
there's an energy to store.
I,
uh,
I had seen a ghost where,
well,
one time I was in the green room and I was,
uh,
I was all alone and I was just writing and get my set ready.
And all of a sudden I hear the,
the,
in the shower,
they have a shower in the green room,
the main room.
I heard the faucet just turning.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
And the water started going.
I'm like,
dude,
that's some crazy shit.
Well,
another time I was,
uh,
promoting the naughty show there and I'd run into the lobby of the main room and
it was completely bright.
And then I ran back and I had to go grab something from my car and they come
back and the room was dark.
And I'm like,
and Jeff Ross in his writing staff from a show where all the,
I'm like,
did you see anyone go through here and turn this off?
They're like,
no,
nobody's come through here since you came through.
I'm like,
okay.
So I started getting a little freaked out.
So I walk into the lobby and it's pitch black,
but there's this weird one light,
this bright white light going against kind of where Tommy used to w stands,
which is kind of where the cashier areas of the main room lobby and it's this
white light and it's kind of a weird reflection coming from sunset street.
It's like bouncing off.
It's coming from,
they're bouncing off the glass door and then it's hitting this thing and I'd
have had no clue how the white light is getting there.
And I'm just looking at also,
and they see just his finger go rape front of light
and I'm just like,
ah,
okay.
I'm fucking Outta here.
And I just went in the other room and made them go turn the lights on.
So you saw something go in front it like this.
Just this,
just figure,
just go right in front of that white light.
Is it possible there was some sort of a reflection from outside?
It's possible,
but it's,
I wouldn't put my,
maybe it's possible,
but all I know is that was light in the lobby.
I come back,
it's pitch black and I just see something go right in front of this white light.
Hmm.
You know,
it's not impossible,
man.
I don't,
I don't think that it's impossible.
I've talked about before on this show about how I believe it's like I believe in
ghosts because I think everything is energy and his transfer of energy and you
always hear like when ghosts happen,
it's always when some violent crime it happened,
which I always think fucks with the transfer,
the energy.
When you get absorbed back in to the whole,
you know the connection,
when your energy goes and you get absorb backed in the some violence fucks with
that transfer and your energy ended up getting,
it's in between here and there.
So that's where the ghosts come from.
Why it might be possible.
I mean the idea was proposed by a guy named Rupert Sheldrake think he's an
evolutionary biologist,
but he had this idea that everything has memory and then let go.
That's why people wouldn't want to buy houses that when people died in them,
that there's a feeling of those,
that those experiences are still stuck in that space.
I don't know if that's true or not,
but my,
uh,
my dad is not a very,
um,
he's my Stepdad,
but he's,
you know,
call my dad.
I don't really know my real dad,
but he's not a,
not a very,
uh,
he's not a spiritual guy,
not a woo guy,
not religious at all,
but he went to Gettysburg and he told me that he had a really bad experience
there.
He said it just like you could feel the death.
He goes,
it feels sad.
It's just like,
there's a feeling there and he goes,
it,
it might be because I knew what happened there.
He goes,
but it didn't feel like it.
He's like,
it just felt like there was something in the place that I could tangibly
interact with.
Yeah.
There's,
I mean,
if something violent and bad happen,
you can feel it in the air.
Yeah.
It is possible.
Right.
Yeah.
I,
again,
it's like my opinion on transfer of energy,
everything's connected.
Might just be something that is really difficult to register.
Something that's really difficult.
Like there's,
there's a lot of people that automatically like shew the idea way shoe.
Any idea why?
If that idea seems to be like a Wacko idea,
like they don't go,
hmm man,
maybe,
but think of God,
how many fucking people have told ghost stories?
Is it possible?
There's something to that is all the imagination.
I mean it could all be the imagination.
It could just be like a,
an archetype that keeps repeating itself over and over again in the human
psyche.
Is it possible that there's things that can't be proven through science in terms
of the what we judge as scientific proof?
I think it's possible.
That could be.
I think it's also possibly it's,
it's also possible that there could be a whole nother dimension that we don't
experience and this man current state,
there might be another dimension.
Consciousness,
lives,
you know,
there,
there might be another dimension where your,
your,
your soul goes after you die.
It sounds ridiculous but so does regular life,
well,
your episode on Psychics,
man,
I totally relate to that.
I mean I've,
I've had,
I just,
again,
I feel like everything's internet connected through energy and that some people
may be able to,
uh,
connect with the energy a little better than other people and maybe they see
stuff that's going to happen maybe,
but the episode on psychics showed more about charlatans and anything.
There was part of that.
But I mean,
personally,
I mean,
that's just one instance in which I personally believe that there are people who
can tap into an energy that other people maybe can't.
It's certainly possible.
I don't,
I can't do it.
Um,
and I couldn't prove anybody could do it on the show and we didn't,
we couldn't get anybody to show us they could do it.
The most likely thing we had on the show was a guy pretending to be psychic that
was telling us in advance that he was,
it's guy a check.
Yeah.
He saw that,
faked it.
And he told us,
he told us in advance,
I'm going to pretend to be psychic.
He fooled a series of scientists for four years with all these tricks that he
does.
I mean he's just a master at,
they won't tell you how he does it,
but he tells you he's doing,
I want to know how he did the,
uh,
the dice.
I want to know how we did all of it.
The dice thing.
I looked at it and he had his hand in his pocket while I was rolling the dice.
And I wonder if there's something in his pocket that registered,
like he could touch it.
And it gives him like two zaps for two,
three Zaps for three.
Like it lets him know like what the number is.
It is possible.
It is possible that he does that.
That could be a possibility.
Oh fine.
Though.
My cousins supposedly can,
if you hand him something,
he can put it in his hand and he could tell you where it's been and what's
happened to it was the smell.
It?
No,
he's got,
it's like,
oh shit.
Oh dice.
Who's the psychic dice?
The psychic.
Hmm.
They lost the credit mother.
I can see you sucking my dick.
Oh,
sexual sidekick.
[inaudible] sidekick.
I feel your weapon.
My balls.
Um,
how will you show what,
yeah,
man,
we did a show with him in Vegas.
I was doing the naughty show at the hard rock casino and in Vinyl,
which is gorgeous club and a man.
That Guy Packs Amanda.
Oh yeah.
Well Dude,
we,
me Norton,
Bobby Kelly,
Anthony Mia,
red band,
and Sam Roberts went to see him at the Riviera.
He was upstairs in the big room and the fucking
killed.
It was hilarious to dice as a master.
It was really funny,
man.
It was really enjoyable.
It was really,
it was,
it was an enjoyable show.
Was a good time watching him do his,
ah,
his Carol's doing the rhymes on a new years.
About eight years ago.
It was one of my favorite moments of comedy because I had grown up on that
stuff.
Hickory dickory dock.
I grew up on that and it crushed.
Yeah,
he was a,
he was a big part of my youth too.
Listen,
I remember listening to him in my car with this girl that I was dating,
just giggling like a couple of retards.
We thought it was so funny.
And that was like the first cassette that he had been that first cassette
zillion before social media and all that stuff.
Oh yeah.
It was on social media.
Well,
he was really unique in that people could repeat his stuff,
you know,
dice,
like you wanted to hear the same stuff over and over again,
like a rock band,
go read deck every doc that people would just start chanting along with it.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
He was great.
He booked today can understand like you can't wrap your head around how big he
was that he was so fucking bay.
And there was this massive backlash from the so called liberal media again,
people who wanted him to be like everybody else.
Yep.
And they couldn't just accept and they couldn't accept also that this was a
character,
like this was a,
this is,
these are his real thoughts and this homophobia and his,
which,
you know,
it did say a lot of like really,
really shit different time.
So what was his homophobia is okay back then?
No.
Well,
it's just a different way of dealing with it.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
people learn,
oh,
you know,
it's like when,
when people get mad at the elderly people for saying racist stuff.
Yeah,
it's not right,
but it's a different time when your grandma show how your colored boyfriend is,
you know,
you don't throw grandma out the window.
It's a just a different time.
It's not right.
Or you a Paula Deen apologists not well.
Well,
hold on Paula Deen.
Listen,
I don't think you should call anyone the n word except for me in bed.
And that's just a true story.
But listen man,
I'm sorry,
but if I hit no,
the story,
right?
If you're robbing me at gunpoint,
is that what the story was?
She got robbed at gun point and said some mean shit.
Oh,
okay.
That's why I thought the story was if you robbed me at gun point,
I'm going to say some nasty
and I think there was like employees involved just call up employees and words.
That's not right.
Dude.
I'm all love.
I love everybody,
Dude.
I love everybody.
We got that.
We got that from you,
Sam.
That's what I've been feeling.
No,
you don't.
You don't feel that I do.
I feel that you don't feel,
I love everybody,
man.
I don't care.
But if you robbed me at gun point,
I'm going to say some names shifts.
One got robbed at gunpoint,
dude.
No,
that's what happened.
she didn't get robbed at gunpoint.
Gumbo.
Oh my God.
Let's see what is wrong with you?
You have a phone dean robbed at gun point.
Why would you,
they asked her,
have you ever used the n word?
And she said yes,
of course.
And they asked her when she was held up at gunpoint,
burst into a bank that I was working 1987 crime she linked to,
oh,
okay.
I'm the asshole.
Well this is,
it was also about her employees were saying,
I agree with that.
I'm just saying that instant in which that's what got her in trouble.
Wait a minute,
is this really,
really
it?
She passed in the 1980s she uttered the racial slur while telling her husband
about being held up at gunpoint by a black.
That's it.
That's
when she used it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm sorry dude,
but I'm sorry dude.
Cause I was saying that you didn't know what you're talking about was actually
me.
I know for a fact that her employees and accused her of doing it,
uh,
employee hold on.
Accused her of racism.
It started because a former manager sued her and that's where the deposition
started.
Yeah.
But how does that have anything to do with getting her getting robbed?
She asked her.
Okay,
hold up.
She asked her employee to dress up like aunt Jemima.
All right,
now it unfolds here.
Oh God.
Yeah.
This is different.
She kiss apparently after the robbery by gunpoint,
she held a grudge on the African American community,
but it also could be like an employee trying to get paid.
It's fucking hard dismissal.
Listen man,
listen,
I don't,
I believe I love,
I love diversity.
That's a big reason.
I love southern California.
Everybody's mixing with everybody.
I prefer it that way.
This guy who worked there said that Dean referred to her and other employees
using a racial slur.
The Times doesn't specify which besides that there is a racially offensive term
for black child.
Oh my goodness.
Do you know what that is?
No.
Niglet oh,
she's horrible.
She must have called them that.
But maybe I'm just making that up though.
They don't dismiss,
but c'mon.
How fucked is it that you could write a story about this but don't want to say
the actual word.
Yeah,
it's,
I don't want to say,
but what it is offensive word for black children.
But say the fucking word.
Why are we pretending that if it's,
if the word is so bad you can't say it,
then it's magic,
then it's,
then it's candy man.
Can,
why I'm at the store and let us know what's going on.
So we know exactly the degree of racism here.
Um,
yeah,
I don't know.
I didn't realize that she was,
I thought she just like had used the word before.
I didn't realize that she had used it because she got robbed.
When you get robbed,
you just fucking call people.
Everything you could think of.
It's when you dealing with a heck,
if you're heckling means we worse than heckling young,
you're relieved like life or death situation.
Possibly.
You'd probably freaking out.
You probably so high on adrenaline and fear.
What does it say?
It got dismissed in case officially closed judge approved dismissal of the case.
So that's the guy
who knows,
man.
You got to look at things like that from a bunch of different angles.
One,
if she is racist,
that's kind of fucked up,
but to she's famous and rich and I'm sure people who work for her look at that
as a target and they're easily could have been something that she,
Paula Dean's robber comes to her defense.
Jeanne Thomas King is the bank robber who Paula Deen says she referred to using
the n word after he robbed her at gunpoint.
King was caught and sentenced to 25 years in prison after the dean robbery and a
separate robbery.
He lives in Brooklyn,
New York now.
And when we spoke to him,
he actually broke down in tears.
He blames himself for Paula Dean's troubles.
I really feel for her.
King said she's being persecuted because that one little mistake in her
judgment,
she was acting out of anger.
Wow.
Look at this guy.
He really came to grips with reality in court.
He had 13 prior convictions for robbery before he pointed his gun.
You need 14 before they can legally be called a nigger.
Yeah,
it's 14 I've seen it.
Um,
and he says that he's turned his life around good for him,
good for him,
and also good for him saying that man,
you know,
that's like that's some clarity that a lot of people are not capable of.
Sometimes people have to actually go through something really fucked up so they
can see like what they're really doing.
Yeah.
Good for that guy.
My life,
my life.
Well,
I don't know if that's the only time she used that word.
Yeah,
I'm with you.
I'm just saying that was the incidence that which I heard in which I would tell
you that if I'm robbed at gunpoint by saying I'm going to say some nasty shit,
it's in the heat of the moment,
you know?
And even afterwards,
two hours later,
if I'm talking to my girl,
I'm going to be like,
oh,
that's weird though.
It's weird that she gets persecuted for that.
If this is nine 1980s,
I mean,
that's 30 years ago,
at least 20 you know,
is it the 19?
What is the exact year?
If it was 1990,
it would be 23 years ago.
She was 19 so it's more than 23 years ago.
Jesus Christ,
you know,
it's like that,
uh,
that,
that uh,
athletic director at Rutgers who's getting in a lot of trouble for saying stuff
that she had said at a previous job decades before that.
And you know,
maybe what she says rough.
But I mean,
people change,
man,
learn it.
You know,
especially myself.
I mean,
the,
the things I've done in my life and that's sometimes how he treated people.
It wasn't right.
You know,
and I,
I've learned and I make amends and I move on and to be judged by something that
happened way long goes.
I think that's a horrible way.
It is horrible.
And it's also,
it's taking out the possibility of someone improving as a human being and
learning from mistakes,
holding you accountable to something that you did 20 years ago or even a fucking
year ago.
Man.
Let's be honest about that.
You're not the person you were a year ago.
If you're constantly evolving and growing,
you mean you might owe an apology for something he did a year ago,
but saying that defines you and a year is kind of stretching it for a lot of
people.
Cause a lot of people are the same person they were a year ago,
but six years ago,
10 years ago.
Are you the same person?
I sure as fuck,
I'm not going to totally different human being than I was 10 years ago.
You,
you,
if you're paying attention and you're working on yourself and you're constantly
trying to think and look at the world objectively,
you're going to grow.
You're going to learn from mistakes and if you're not making any mistakes,
you're not taking any fucking,
yeah,
it's my whole theory.
I was talking about on stage about how everyone got mad at the NSA and there was
people like,
I don't care.
I've got nothing to hide.
It's like who doesn't have anything to hide man?
Like are you not living any life?
That's not the point.
Anyway,
the point is not the nothing that that idea is so silly.
I've got nothing to hide.
Well it doesn't matter.
You can't give people that kind of power.
The saying something like that is just without a doubt being ignorant about
human behavior cause absolute power.
There's the old quote PR corrupts.
Absolutely.
It always has.
And when you give someone the ability to look in on your email,
Snowden was saying that he could just read people's emails,
you can just target Sam Aaa and you start reading your emails.
Oh God.
And he didn't even have a high school education that you can't give people that
power.
You can't give people the power to stalk.
You can't give people the law,
the power to peer in let's creeper shit and you don't have to do anything wrong.
I mean we looked at,
I mean there are through history,
we've seen people who are profiled by agencies and you know,
he frank Sinatra,
Martin Luther king who weren't necessarily doing anything wrong but they were
being monitored.
It's like you don't have to do something wrong to be monitored.
Well that's the j Edgar Hoover days.
And before that of course the McCarthyism,
but the McCarthy era is a classic example of people being persecuted and people
being singled out and people being spied upon and categorize these dangerous and
divisive groups.
That kind of behavior is unconstitutional for a reason.
Looking into people's lives is a violation of privacy and it's unconstitutional
for reasoning.
We have to recognize that there is always been people that are looking to
capitalize on the holes that we have in our system and they will create false
flags and through those false flags,
these events will cause them to clamp down more on security.
It will curl.
Interesting,
right?
It's ridiculous,
but it's true.
They will create artificial problems so that they will have a solution.
Create a problem,
propose a solution,
get what you want.
What did you want?
We wanted to be able to control people.
We want them to Norway,
alien society.
How do we go about doing it?
What were you going to have to have a threat and you're going to have to have
this threat,
let's call it terrorism.
Terrorism is a good threat because it's so undefined.
It's not like we conquer one nation and our terrorism problem is over.
It continues forever and for people to think that some tinfoil hat conspiracy
bullshit,
you're really not paying attention because it's happened.
It's happened over and over and over again.
Yeah.
I mean even if you talk about conspiracy theories with some people,
they can't even begin to understand it because they're looking at through their
point of view.
My whole thing is like if you ever watch the first 48 man,
it's this great show.
It's about it sadly,
about murder and Marie real murder investigation.
You see people killing other people for $20 dollars.
Now just imagine if there was $1 billion on the line,
$1 trillion on the line,
just because someone's in the suit,
they're not standing on a corner,
they're going to act different.
No,
it's all primal basic thing.
This special pull the trigger themselves.
Yeah.
It's designed to get as much resources as possible.
That's what it's all about.
I mean,
it's basic human behavior and if you can get it through the guise of war,
it's really easy to get things done.
You just hire much and now they have mercenaries.
I mean there,
during the Bush administration,
they started using mercenaries for the first time in God knows how long man
openly using like blackwater and all these other companies go in and do a bunch
of shit.
Those dudes in Afghanistan,
I know some of those dudes,
I have friends that went over there and did some work for them.
I have a friend who was a sniper in the marines and he made more money in doing
that than he ever did doing anything.
He would go over there for a few months at a time,
made like 30 grand a month,
come back bank man.
But it's like that guy in Chicago who went around and and fortunately killed all
those people shooting.
You know what that was about?
That was them trying to take over territory.
They thought that area,
that,
that block or that,
that uh,
that blacktop was another gangs territory and they didn't care who they shot.
They just wanted to shoot.
Yeah.
So they don't care if they take out 13 people,
they just want to gain a certain amount of power.
And resources.
Same thing like you know the government does something where I'll bunch people
die.
Any of,
whether it's 1002003000 5,000 whatever,
it doesn't matter in the bigger picture of everything.
Yeah,
and they also know that time will continue to roll on.
More conflicts will arise and people forget about it.
Constant state of war.
Yeah.
People forget about so many different things that happened in the past.
They forget about different bombs that went off different.
They're going to forget about this mall in Africa after a while people are going
to forget about,
you know the,
the bomb,
the,
the Iraqi's blew up on the u s warship.
There's,
there's so many different events in the course of a decade of war plus that
we've been involved in that they can just tally them all up and push them all
aside.
As long as there's some new thing in the news to think about,
people will keep thinking.
Do you feel it?
This naval yard thing hit as hard as Mosley.
I feel like it happened and everyone's like,
Nah,
another one.
Yeah.
We're getting desensitized.
Video.
What is this video of the guy shooting?
Anyone that's coming in with all your weapons and stuff?
Yeah,
it's pretty chilly.
Yeah.
I don't want to see it either,
but it's,
um,
yeah,
this is more where we're used to it.
They're Aurora,
Colorado.
One would now kind of forgot about it.
We're thinking about a new thing now where people are going to keep sanctity.
You're going to keep thinking about new things,
keeps,
keeps sticking things in front of their face and they forget about something
that happened a month ago.
Hey,
can I ask you,
I know in England the law enforcement doesn't carry guns,
but it does.
I know Canada has very strict gun laws,
right?
Does Canadian police carry?
Yes.
Yeah,
they have guns.
I always felt that that was a big issue with gun.
With England's.
It certainly is.
Yeah.
England.
It really is.
You know,
and there's a,
you know,
there's arguments both ways.
The problem with guns is like that expression.
You can't take p out of the pool once they're out there,
they're out there and in England and out there nearly as much as they are in
America.
They don't have nearly as many gun violence crimes,
but we do,
you know,
we do.
We,
we,
and people have the right to protect themselves.
You know,
it's not like you're going to round up all the guns.
They're not going to let you,
this country is not going to let you round up all the guns.
We've got a,
we've got a sticky situation.
I think it's more of a mental health situation than it is anything.
I completely agree.
100% sky,
the Aurora shooter,
the kids that were in,
um,
the,
uh,
the Columbine kids,
they're all medicated.
They're all fucked up on,
they're on drugs.
They're,
they're heads are fucked up.
Their heads are fucked up.
Maybe before they were on drugs,
maybe can't even blame the,
the psychic,
the psychotropic drugs that they're on.
But the bottom line is they're all Scott.
That's the common denominator.
Mentally ill,
it's not guns.
There's a lot of same people with guns that never shoot anybody.
If it wasn't guns,
they'd find another thing.
I just wonder if people will eventually evolve to the point where we stopped
shooting each other with guns.
Stop murdering each other.
Is that possible?
Is that uh,
there's a lot less murder then there was like in the fucking 12 hundreds back
during the Mongol days and shit like that.
But it's still,
yeah,
one little more civilized.
I always think it has so much to do with people shooting guns.
Cause in the movies what you'll see is somebody will shoot somebody and then the
walkway and then like there'll be able to go shoot somebody else.
Like there isn't an instant law enforcement situation that comes in,
hunts them down there.
Like the one move you would Steven Seagal.
I think it was above the law where that one guy goes on this crime spree for
like a whole day and he just killing everybody and no point.
Do you see law enforcement anywhere?
You know,
he just moves on to the next crime,
moves onto the next crime.
Like I just feel people feel like they could shoot somebody and just easily get
away with it.
Um,
what,
yeah,
well that was my just tie right that nobody's talking about.
I just heard it equated above the law where the real life,
some people have been to gore movie like a an important point.
My point,
I just use it as an example,
meaning that I feel that a lot of people who go off on the,
and a,
like in Chicago,
they started shooting people.
I think when you watch television or even movies,
there's always someone who gets shoot somebody and he just walks off and his
life goes on.
He's never worried about the cops,
the cops.
I had friends in a lot of places where the cops aren't there,
but that's why I think it happens as much is that people don't think there's any
ramifications for shooting somebody as much as there really is.
Do you know what I'm saying?
No.
Okay.
Maybe I've just went off on a,
this is some weird thing as wasn't in my head.
That's caffeine.
Talking to Simon.
I don't know what you're talking about.
People know that if you get caught shooting people,
you go to jail.
Yeah,
but I,
I think people think they're going to get away with it.
That's why really who,
I think that's a lot of these people who shoot guns,
they think they're going to get away and be like mass shootings.
All,
all of them.
I don't think they think they're getting to get away with it.
I think they're on a suicide run.
Well maybe that guy's on a suicide run,
but these people go right,
go around.
They just walk up and they shoot their drug dealer.
They think they're going to get away with it because they know what they think.
I,
this is my opinion,
I'm staying in opinion for the,
for the purpose of discussion,
we're gonna bring the song because we only have a couple minutes left over.
It was
good to be back.
I've never been in the studio.
Good to have you back on the show again.
Anytime.
We'll be back next week.
My,
my lovely friends,
we have,
uh,
lots of,
fun guests coming up.
I kinda got a gang of people coming up over the next few weeks,
some really interesting guests for the month of,
uh,
October two we got Greg Proops is coming back and Rocktober yeah.
Of a bunch of people.
Um,
lots of,
uh,
lots of fun guests.
And of course our friends.
We don't know where we're going to do for the 400th episode.
This is what?
97,
three 98.
This is three 98.
So three 99 is the next one.
So in two next baby,
next week we'll hit 400.
Uh,
I don't know what we're gonna do.
I'll probably get on Joey Diaz and Dunkin and have some fun and uh,
that's it.
My friends.
We'll see you this weekend,
Sam Tripoli and I,
and you can ask Sam to elaborate on is Steven Seagal slash shoot someone and get
away with it.
Theory.
I will.
Thanks to for Lumosity for sponsoring us.
Go to lumosity.com.
Tell them Joe Rogan sent you.
Don't use the comma bitch.
Don't use Joe Rogan,
bitch or bitch Joe Rogan.
Don't use that.
Just Joe Rogan to whatever you fucking want to do it.
Don't listen to me.
It's America.
Thanks to audible.com go to audible.com forward slash Joe get a free audio book
and 30 free days of audible service.
Thanks also to onnit.com go to o,
n n.
I.
T use the code named Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
Thank you everybody for all the love on mine.
All the people that come to the shows,
the the love on Twitter and all the cool articles that you guys sent me.
A,
we're all in the shit together.
The Freak party roles on for 2013 that's the new party I'm in.
I'm not represented by debit treasure,
public cabinetry or the Libertarians.
You can't handle money.
You don't know what the fuck you're to freak freak party 2013 14 and beyond.
All right,
fuckers.
See you next week.